there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock okay here we are back again
for an episode 132 going back into the
true crime Ted Bundy we're talking about
Ted Bundy King of Kings really well this
dude here man we're gonna get into this
everybody knows everybody should know
this name alright most people know the
victims they kind of know the
generalized story but maybe they haven't
read the books that he told you what he
was doing behind the scenes [ __ ] that
came out later yeah I mean there's this
weird common misconception that or
misperception may be that this guy is
some kind of gentleman bandit that he
just goes up raped women maybe just
chokes him you know then they die and
then he moves on to the next one that
he's kind of like a high as a lot
high-profile killer breed he just goes
after these pretty girls with these long
hair and you know he he did kill the
cream of the crop really you know I mean
but they don't tell you that this dude
also had sex with heads and that he was
a necrophile and did only he was bad
dude with batteries come yeah it's gone
here's it well this is another thing
where I feel like people that are
perceived as good looking or decent
looking I can get away with Marsha yeah
because here's the thing now I had had
Ted Bundy on the list for a while
because like I said we're eventually
gonna get around to doing all the serial
killers um so I was gonna I had plan to
do this like in a month or two but then
the Netflix series the Ted Bundy tapes
came out and I got a couple messages
going hey why don't you guys do Ted
Bundy so I was like okay well I'll push
it up in the list and you will do it
sooner than I was gonna do it so you
know we're trying to cash in a little
bit I guess but not really because I was
gonna do it anyways but then the Netflix
series came out now we did watch the
Netflix series
which was really good but the weird
thing about it is that they showed him
in a good light actually it did kind of
get like that kind of like weirded me
out yeah and they should with that judge
said about it you know you'd have made a
good lawyer I don't have anything
against you boy yeah I like man if you
knew the I'm not sure that I'm not sure
the judge knew the details of the case
is like yeah I don't know what did I
don't know what that judge was sucking
thinking I never would have said that
[ __ ] to him I'd have been like you need
to ride to hell dude
if that [ __ ] was ugly yeah the judge
would never have said that and then we
are always going on about how
intelligent Ted Bundy isn't really and
he was crazy as a [ __ ] loon he'd be
driving down the road and I was sitting
to have panic attacks and pull his
clothes off throw him out the window and
then realize that he was driving naked
and had to go back and get his clothes
I'm not talking about a criminal
mastermind no and the thing about him is
that he's one of those dudes and I think
I talked about this a little bit when we
were talking about the Moors Murders of
Brady and Hindley and I was talking
about Ian Brady the Ian Brady and Ted
Bundy seem to have very similar
personality types whereas like you're a
dude that's like a little bit more
intelligent than average but you think
you're way more intelligent than you
actually are
because people that are actually
intelligent they realize that there's so
much [ __ ] that they don't know so in a
way it's kind of more humbling people
that are just a little bit intelligent
they think they're smarter than
everybody else on earth and I feel like
Ted Bundy had some of that should get
one on I've always said you know here on
the show that serial killers are graded
on a curve they're graded on a bell
curve so yeah Bundy well you probably
put him ahead of a lot of the other ones
because he did complete some aspects of
law school he could carry himself to a
certain extent in society during a
conversation yeah but now really he was
mostly just a pretty much a thin veneer
there were yeah it wasn't as smart as he
claimed to be or thought he was yeah he
wasn't as well-versed to being a lawyer
I mean he was he was a D student
you're not on an instant he was a deist
and he actually admitted when he went
into law school and I mean he only got
in like his admissions test he got
shitty scores on them he only got in
because of you know he knew some kind of
powerful people that gave him
recommendations he got in there and he
even admitted that in his first year law
school classes that he found the classes
quote unquote incomprehensible he had
like no idea and he didn't and he said
the other students seem to understand
[ __ ] that or they had seemed to have
some intellectual capacity that I didn't
have so he was like smart enough to
realize that he wasn't as smart as he
thought but they're smart enough to fake
it yeah be smarter to fake it and he
could kind of talk the talk he really
couldn't walk the walk but he couldn't
kind of talk the talk a little bit yeah
you know if if you ever study you know
lawyers and look at the look at legal
systems and their need they're very
state state the United States law isn't
all it's cracked up to be either you
don't mean that
those guys are [ __ ] artists you know
I mean lawyers are [ __ ] artists
that's kind of part of the job
they're they're instructing a narrative
there yeah there are a lot like D&D role
player type guys you know and that mixed
with used-car salesmen there's you know
a doctor has more to him than your
average lawyer does yeah I don't want
you know there may be lawyers out in the
audience thought I'd work piss anybody
off a lawyer is a modern-day version of
a priest really what it is there's very
much like the priest class you know
whereas you know what the hell Kate
Canon Cameron she's just everything Emma
sewed she's like I'm gonna come in here
and angles
you know you might back in the olden
days you might give some money to a
priest and he'd said you know he'd say a
prayer and give you a blessing and then
you'd build a house in a location and be
all right nowadays got to go to a lawyer
and pay him and they argue for it and
then you know get you some zoning laws
restructured and then your house appears
there like like a magic
magician that's what they are and pay
them in eight like I said they construct
this construct this elaborate narrative
on paper and says yes you can build that
house that your innocence or thank you
to chain you know it's the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know really but yeah so the
thing about it and like I said I I liked
the Ted Bundy tapes like I've seen a lot
of documentaries about Ted Bundy because
there's like a million but the Ted Bundy
tapes was really you know I guess they
wanted to focus on you know the the
interviews with him you know while he
was on death row that were done so a lot
of it was in his own voice but it did
seem like the the victims were kind of
just like not really mentioned all that
much like they were but they just kind
of like skated over the [ __ ] and you
know they they kind of said a lot of
stuff about like you said they almost
like tried to like build him up like he
was this big like he was so charming and
he was so handsome and he was so smart
and he was this that the other thing he
was just better than you would expect I
just thought that was really weird but
like it was a pedophile - he killed
[ __ ] young girls even though he never
admitted to that but he was killing me
underage girls - yeah he was but yeah
and the thing about Ted Bundy too is
that there's really no way of knowing I
mean he's credited generally with
credited I hate to use that word but you
know he's usually thought to have killed
somewhere between 30 and 36 women but
they think it's probably more than that
because there are a lot like he
confessed to some whose bodies they
never found there were some crimes that
happened that seemed like he probably
did them like in areas where he was
living at the time but he would never
admit to that the age the right usually
if it was somebody that was like lived
close by if it was somebody very young
like he would never admit that he had
done it so and he has like all these
different kind of stories - about like
which ones he killed and all this other
kind of stuff so you can't take anything
he says seriously I mean because he just
tells stories
um so I think there's that issue they
know that he killed at least 30 and it's
probably far far more than that you know
and he's just such a [ __ ] and like I
said the interesting thing about
watching the Ted Bundy tapes is that I
was interested to watch it because I
wanted to see how much insight that he
had into his own behavior like why he
did it he doesn't really seem to have
that much no he came across as very glib
and very like superficial and he talked
about everything in the third person
like he couldn't take responsibility he
was weaselly guy weaselly yeah came
across yeah and really I don't know why
this guy gets you know the notoriety
that he did in fact you know some people
said that you know that we kind of
inspired Hannibal Lecter when when they
wrote that book Silence of the Lambs and
and I would disagree I would say now now
I would probably say really more closer
more closely to Hannibal Lecter would be
the original Night Stalker yeah and what
was his name they caught him recently
just Angela Joseph D'Angelo did I would
you put me in same room with Ted Bundy
I'd [ __ ] him up okay
D'Angelo in his prime yeah I'd be
worried about that guy you know I mean
he was a cop he was in the direct
confrontation
he'd overpower you you know yeah with
guns and tactics no ambush surprise
ambushes not Bundy Bundy was just a
weaselly guy you know he would go after
some weak girls and talk him into [ __ ]
you trick but he would just go after
college girls and be like oh my legs
broken like my crowbar right and then he
would put like [ __ ] handcuffs on
D'Angelo would go after you while you
were there with your wife he'd go after
your wife while you were there not that
we're saying that's good no that takes a
little bit more balls yeah that's a more
dangerous man if he asked me much more
dangerous man well thankfully he's in
prison
yeah and Ted
even though I'm gonna say D'Angelo if
you're out there listening you might
think you're brave is [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
got caught eventually you know you have
a little dick all the things I'm saying
knows that y'all said you had a little
dick so yes and then Frank last I heard
that [ __ ] is still not talking yes but
like I said I feel like that's some like
Teddy they feel like they want to
control everything like to the very end
but like I said so that was one thing
that bothered me like I can say like the
Ted Bundy tapes did come across in a
sense that Ted Bundy particularly when
he got arrested and he was like
representing himself or he like took
over from the lawyers that were assigned
to him it did kind of show that he was
way in over his head and he was just
like sabotaging his own case it pretty
much every opportunity just because he
wanted to be in control he wanted to
tell everyone else what to do even if he
was [ __ ] up his whole entire on this
show we're gonna give you the lowdown on
Bundy and we're also gonna do mystify
some [ __ ] so you can walk with him this
show having an accurate view who did who
Ted Bundy sorry ass was yeah then we
have to probably have some shoutouts
what's been going on in the show okay
not a lot we're just gonna do like some
really brief ones um as I said faceless
villain volume one the audio elements
[ __ ] awesome has been re-recorded and
it should be the new recording should be
up by the time this show comes out
because this is going up on February 21
also check out our last movie
retrospective which was the Clint
Eastwood movie High Plains Drifter
dimension unseen hand the unseen hand
thought of addition to of the audiobook
yeah I'm recording that is being
recorded right now yeah yeah and that's
not a that's not a very big book in
comparison to say like you know faces
villain to which this will have good
progress on that so probably wanted to
be a matter of weeks maybe yeah hear
this so yeah I'm so that means all three
of Jenny's new heavy-hitter books will
all be in really good audio format
be relaunched we'll go back and we're
gonna go we're gonna release after that
we want to do the fiction yeah I'm going
to record my theory do math not
poltergeist and then we'll redo the to
Steve Mara books and then plus like I
said I also have to work on faceless
villain 3 because I want that [ __ ] out
before the end writer like the print and
the audio to Mara books are not very
long though hopefully we yeah get new
audio for that so yeah this is wrong
this year
like I said faceless volume 3 should be
out the book you know the print book
ebook and audiobook and all of the every
thing should be out an audio book
hopefully that's what I'm shooting this
year for this by the end of the June of
this year so it's a reconsolidation year
we launched everything yeah and then
after that we'll see how it goes yeah
never that we'll have a free hand to do
anything me if it's a faces fill in for
or if it's something totally new we're
gonna cut it with something we're gonna
come up with something you guys want
yeah um also like I said and I say every
week if you want to support the show and
go to patreon our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and in the sidebar there's a little
button that says donate with paypal and
you can click on that and it'll go right
to a PayPal account that goes right to
us also I wanted to mention again I
mentioned it on our last show on
Mackinac Island but if you go to the
game crafter calm and you search for
giallo games GI I have some games that I
designed on there if you're into that
kind of [ __ ] I have one called a crimson
drop on a crystal palette and it's kind
of like a clue style kind of card game
that's the main game right there and I
also have an expansion pack I also have
one that is very much like schmoovy
except it's giallo based like you come
up with jello it's like movies like with
the cards in here that have like jello
style words on them it's called the
cursive names of nightmares and that is
for sale also and I also have the
which is the Gorga lor expansion pack
for that which has kind of more bloody
type of words I also have a game which
is like a board game kinda and it's like
it's called the three Sorrows and it's
kind of like a build as you go type of
board so that should be I ordered a
proof copy which should be coming in a
week or two so by the time this show
comes out it might be up for sale so go
check it out if you want to check that
it's actually like a really big game
with like a really big board and all
this other kind of stuff so I check out
jello games on the game crafter yeah if
you would we didn't get some of that too
beer and board games let that I know I
need to send some of those okay now
we've had some positive comments from
new subscribers if you're a new
subscriber please share the show help us
grow we're coming up on 6,000
subscribers
the next goal we have is 10,000
yeah we can yeah we could do it because
the bigger we get the faster we grow
yeah so please share the show with
others give us a good shout outs and
stuff and after you get everything
redone with the audio books we need to
get you back on tour as a guest on some
of these podcasts yeah if you guys know
of other true-crime or paranormal
podcast you'd like Jenny to appear on
that do interviews they do interviews oh
please drop something in the comment box
down there and we'll see if we can
contact him send Jenny on tour yeah
because she's an awesome guest she's
been on a lot I haven't been on a lot of
true-crime [ __ ] I've been on a lot of
paranormal shows like I'm a little less
but you know I would think on the back
of unseen hand that you could get on a
good feeling you can get on some I get
him so confused mission I'm drinking
rokubu con I tell you he's unveiling
himself to me
wait is that your second one my second
one last last week's show at Mackinac
Island it was like two hours long
because like I said what we started
doing was we started recording more than
one episode at one time yeah so we
actually recorded a movie retrospective
before we did this show yeah
and he sort of drinking during that oh
yeah this might be another like - yeah I
might try to keep I'm gonna try to keep
it on the subject okay ten and you
Theodore and you actually you know that
it should be good because you I've read
a lot about write a lot about Gandhi so
it's so it's not just me with the
research and he's like he's like a um
you know if you guys have ever like gone
to the movies with like like old men and
how and I I think I've told this story
before but I remember this is as though
it was yesterday I went with my friend
Jen to see Jurassic Park in the theater
the first one and that was what like
1993 or some [ __ ] like that so we're
sitting in the theater watching [ __ ]
Jurassic Park and there's an old couple
bus they were like a hundred and twenty
I swear to God they were like [ __ ]
the crypt keeper's back so like this old
guy in this old woman yeah and this
movie is going on and we're enjoying the
dinosaurs and whatnot and then this old
man he had no idea was going this movie
he's like every time a new characters
who's this now let's go that what is
this and then like he was you remember
the part where like the dinosaur like
yes they put the goat out and the does
he goes it eight to go
and I turned around like thank you thank
you we're all watching the same you know
what you're watching and I'm sure his
poor wife was she saw a video some old
guy that age going down to the
supermarket a little buffet table where
they have all the soups yeah and he's
getting this serving spoons out there
and he's tasted them all put them back
in the soup and she did you know how the
grocery stores like having the bar with
the soups and like that like Italian
food
why not so like this old fart and
somebody like tape do with their from
like yeah and like they reported it to
thank you for all the see one I wonder
yeah I wonder how so man is gross god I
don't want to know Wow
yeah whoa people that's uh maybe he had
dementia yeah dementia a hell of a drug
oh yeah we have to actually you know
with our other with the other show that
we do you know with the our matinee show
we have to avoid Tuesdays well because
NC theaters Tuesdays are $5 ticket days
now we go we try to go like in the early
afternoon we usually go to like you know
12:30 1:00 o'clock shows something like
that when we can manage it but we we
started doing them on Tuesdays sometimes
and it got to a point where because the
tickets were cheap it was like all full
of old people and they are so it's
another generation broke it's another
generation I'm sorry it's like old
people like I'm old too I'm sure
coming up at 50 you know Jenny's not too
far behind me but there's something
about boomers that boomer generation
when they start getting into their 7 mid
70 70 75 mm close to 80 well what it
might be a thing we're very
self-centered well they wear one they're
old and they don't give a [ __ ] anymore
about anybody else - they might be deaf
so they don't know how loud they're
talking um but I do feel like they kind
of come in the theater like other day uh
we're sitting there I don't remember
what what was it we were once it might
have been with tell me story no Taylor
Louie would remember there was like a
whole row there was like five of them
and they sat like right behind us and
then they were all they have all the
heads like allowed his food opening
packages and then they were talking like
at the top of their voices like I think
it was it might have been they will not
grow old or that camera now no but I
don't think it was that one maybe maybe
it was destroyer I think was destroyer
they might have been um
but yeah so we get like this you know
whole pack of old people what is like
what is a group of old people called a
gaggle a denture I don't know one thing
about it is that they it's a big social
event to go to the movies they're gonna
sit around and go talk to each other
before it after the movie so when you
come out of the theater to try to do our
reviews they're gonna sit there right in
the
hallways hanging out like teenagers I
know just and they'll just see Apple do
I would rather go see a movie with the
whole movie theater full of teenagers
yeah a teenager at least they're mostly
usually quiet yeah and they run around
old people are not quiet the man that
teenagers today man they're [ __ ] I'll
tell you but that one time that [ __ ]
gunshots happened in that and that Aeon
Flux or what were there was that it was
movie remember the old Natalie Portman
movie yeah the school shooting happened
did half of ran out what they never came
back
yeah that was yeah but yeah I would
rather go see movies with teenagers
because old people Venus Lux there was
called no what was that called I don't
remember what it was called it was an
okay movie box locks now although I
didn't expect that [ __ ] [ __ ] either
at the beginning so we're doing that now
yeah yeah but yeah so but yeah so the
old people in the movies I don't know I
don't know what to tell you yeah but
anyway all right so let's get back to
talking about Ted Bundy before you go
off on some other you're doing it going
off no I wasn't okay I was just like
joka all right so now here's the thing
Ted Bundy was actually not his name when
he was born he was actually born
Theodore Robert Cal now his mother when
he was born was in one of those in the
40s back in the old days when you got
knocked up and you weren't married they
would stick you in like an unwed mothers
home yes can't like a modern version
because of the shame yeah so that's
where he was born he was born in this
place called the Elizabeth blond home
for unwed mothers I wonder what happened
if the dad was black wonder what they
would do to you back in those days
probably kill you yeah I don't know I'm
sure that happened a lot yeah so um
they're actually not real sure who his
dad was on his birth certificate
there was the name was Lloyd Marshall
but actually later on his mom said no it
was this other guy like a sailor and his
name was Jack Worthington but they never
found anyone with that name like that
had been in the Navy or the Merchant
or anything like that so they don't know
how true that is so they don't actually
know who Ted Bundy's dad is and it
actually has been speculated that 10 but
Ted Bundy's dad might be his mom's dad
like his grandfather okay but there's
like no solid proof of that so don't
so it's rumored that he may have been
inbred yeah okay but like I said there's
no proof of that so don't you know
wonder where that rumor started from so
like I said she might've just been some
goofy [ __ ] yeah so now here's the
[ __ ] up thing for much of his life
Bundy actually believed that his mom was
his sister because of the whole shame of
like unwed mothers blah blah blah so
when she brought baby Bundy home the
grandparents essentially raised him as
their own yeah and didn't tell him that
his sister sister mom was actually his
mom yeah and I don't understand why what
people thought back then like they
thought that was gonna be good for a
kid's mental health I don't think they
gave much of a [ __ ] about kids myself
back then clearly yes that's why we had
so many no no one was thinking about the
older generations really were you know I
mean they were [ __ ] up [ __ ] up they
didn't think right there think it is
they were very the Overton Window was
very small the things that were
acceptable you know the range of
acceptability was very small so normal
life got in the way of [ __ ] [ __ ] them up
bad yeah like I said that that might be
another reason but talked about it
before like why there were somebody
[ __ ] up serial killers in the 60s and
70s because they were weird back then
because people they got raised back then
their families were messed up yeah a
little bit might have been yeah with
them yeah what was normal was kind of
weird well and I should say too and I
think I've mentioned this before on
other shows about serial killers is that
you know just because you were raised in
a fucked-up family because I know a lot
of people were you know probably many of
our listeners were probably people most
people that grew up back then and [ __ ]
at families that doesn't mean that
you're gonna turn into a serial killer
you get a kick puppies or whatever like
that but I think you have to have a
predisposition in that direction and
then on top of it like you know the
cherry on the shits
you know you get raised in this thing
and it just pushes you over the edge I
stopped my observances all families are
[ __ ] up in their own way just a matter
of what degree yeah degree of [ __ ] done
or the nature of the [ __ ] Davis mm-hmm
so yeah I do definitely think so I don't
think that things can be entirely blamed
on genetics but please you know things
can't be entirely blamed on your
upbringing either because a lot of
people have fucked-up childhood didn't
turn out just fine so I think you
already have to be geared toward that
and then you have the fucked-up
childhood and then that kind of gives
you an extra push to work and being
[ __ ] up oh it has them and do the
extremes extremely religious or
extremely anti religious you don't want
really you want to be somewhere in the
middle that's where the normality is yes
me yeah nothing nothing it's nothing no
extremists kind of extremist background
seems to cause conflict in kids yeah now
there is actually some controversy and
as I said you know you can't take
anything Ted Bundy says at face value
because he says different things to
different people
so there's actually there's no consensus
on when he found out that his sister was
actually his mom yes so there's no
consensus like you know one biographer
he told him yeah I figured it out like
my cousin called me a bastard and like
you know I asked somebody and they told
me you know he told someone else that oh
I didn't figure out till I was in
college you know when he went and looked
for his birth certificate or whatever um
so there's you know I don't I don't know
when he found out nobody knows when he
found out but this was look I really the
book I read said that he found out more
or less around high school there yeah
that's what that's yeah he knew he knew
his sister was his mommy resented her
for for it
yeah I thought she was weak yeah and
there's also some controversy about how
he related to his grandparents who
that were his parents for a long time
his grandfather he said that yeah I
related to him and he was cool and
everything like that but other family
members have said no he was a he was
horrible he was a bully he was a puppy
kicker like I said you know he abused
animals you know he was kind of like
racist he hated Jews he hated Catholics
and apply he had everybody pretty much
you know and beat up his wife and yada
yada you know and beat up on you know
his on Ted's aunt julia stuff like that
now Archie Bunker yeah he was like that
except not funny in the least now there
are also some stories that Ted Bundy
showed like I said a predisposition for
being messed up even when he was a kid
because according to Julia who was his
aunt she was actually taking a nap in
the house one day and woke up and there
were knives all around her body like
pointing at her and then Ted who was
only like three at the time was like
standing there looking at her like hey
you know what I mean so there were some
hints that he might not have been like
right even from the beginning so later
on his mom this was in 1950 I think Ted
was about four years old um she changed
her last name and then she went to live
in Tacoma Washington they had you know
she had been living they had in Vermont
and then to Philadelphia and then they
moved to Tacoma Washington um at this
point in 1951 when Ted was and she took
Ted with her so I don't know I mean like
I said at this point he didn't know that
that wasn't his mom but whatever he just
thought oh my sister okay whatever so
they go to Tacoma she meets a guy named
Johnny Bundy who worked in a hospital as
a cook she met him at a singles night at
a Methodist Church slicked mixer yeah
now he now johnny Bundy adopted Ted
which is where he got the last name of
Ted Bundy obviously and later on like
Johnny Bundy
Ted Bundy's mom Louise had four kids at
their own now according to everyone in
the family the stepdad actually did try
to like include Ted and stuff like he
would take him fishing and he would like
do fun stuff with him and everything but
Ted was not having it so um you know he
was very distant you know he he said
that he didn't like him as a person he
thought he was dumb that he didn't make
enough money like all that kind of stuff
like later on he said that kind of [ __ ]
so like I said you know how much of this
can be believed I don't know because a
lot of this comes from what Ted Bundy is
saying too later well true and he told
people different things it sounds true
because everything I remember about
Bundy based on my readings is that he
was very superficial very materialistic
he did very status or yeah
and that's always a sign of insecurity
they come from nothing you don't have
much consideration for yourself as a
person everything is about the trappings
you can put on yourself yeah yeah
appearances and if you know you're good
enough yeah serial killer sister yeah
it's typically very very much like you
know all about appearances just
superficial yeah and him more than most
yeah um you know I I think he's kind of
whole thing like you said it had to do
with insecurity feeling like never being
good enough and you feel like oh well if
I just put on enough trappings of you
know like ability or trappings of oh I
have a lot of money or I'm successful or
that people don't like me usually wealth
and status yeah but but rather than just
being a likable but a lot of times it's
fake wealth and status yeah it's not
real wealth and status yeah they'll buy
jewelry and nice clothes but they don't
have a house yeah yeah I mean they don't
own a bunch of cars they don't have a
business or anything just a
superficiality of it yeah you know and
you know they can't get into Harvard but
maybe they might wear a Harvard ring or
some stupid [ __ ] like that like you know
what I mean it's like if you just work
at McDonald's just work like that that's
cool you know I don't know but some
people think the character before career
your bottom I'm military school if
you're a cool person
I don't give a [ __ ] what you do for a
job or how much baking they can take
everything from you except your
character they can't take that from you
exactly that's what I think you just be
a cool person and that's what's real not
another [ __ ] all the other [ __ ] doesn't
matter because even the richest person
like could how much people buy all that
stuff by I know I was what I was gonna
say is that even the richest person
could lose all their money yeah and
nothing and then have nothing right so
you know although a lot of time a person
that has good character and [ __ ] you
know I mean they just make money kind of
automatically as part of their character
but other ones are just artificially
kind of born with it or they go to the
right schools which is kind of like
opening doors for them yeah to make a
bunch of money but it's on them to
continue to make money cuz just because
you graduate from Harvard doesn't
guarantee that you won't get fired yeah
- Ted Bundy I think graduated from
Harvard I think he did I think he did
graduate from Margaret not Ted Bundy I
meant what was his name
Unabomber what's his now context in ski
when you graduate from Harvard and that
[ __ ] lived in a shack yeah yeah made
in made bombs cuz he was crazy as [ __ ]
he rationalized it all with whatever
they all do he was into the green
movement everything was about stopping
industry yeah so like I said you know
like I was saying before a lot of the
[ __ ] about Ted Bundy's upbringing about
his childhood it comes from his own
perceptions which are not necessarily
accurate because he did tell different
people different things like he did tell
some biographers yeah like I spent a lot
of my childhood like digging through
trash barrels like looking for crime
magazines like with naked women like and
you know murdered women pictures and
[ __ ] like that in there then later on he
told another buyer friend never do that
I don't know why anybody reads that crap
blah blah blah um you know so it was
that whole thing and he also said that
when he was a teenager he would like to
like drink a lot and like go canvass the
neighborhood like peep in people's
windows and stuff like that I don't know
if he actually did that but he did tell
one biographer
again in high school he seemed to say
that he was kind of like um a loner but
that he chose to be that way like he
felt like distant from other people he
said that I didn't understand like why
people wanted to be friends with other
people or why or like how that happened
like he seemed kind of not to understand
interpersonal relationships I think he
was a high-functioning psychopath yeah
he really did seem like that and and
some one biographer or somebody that I
was reading said that or she was a
psychiatrist rather and she said you
know I always tell my students that I
don't think true Psychopaths really
exist or they're very rare but she's
like if they did exist Ted Bundy would
be one yeah so he definitely gives all I
think almost everyone has come across a
pathological liar in which he definitely
seen this type of action you know I mean
I've come across one during high school
one of our buddies was a pathological
liar now eventually we couldn't hang out
with any Morgan oh [ __ ] wouldn't stop
lying but once you come across a
pathological liar every time I come
across one they had that same field
their personality is that same character
type it's almost like something genetic
yeah you recognize it
like the president blue eyes you see it
yeah if a person is a pathological liar
you see it there's a certain aspects to
the way they talk and everything their
mannerisms are seem to be the same
serial killer has that too yeah you know
I mean it just said they there's
something about them that's kind of like
a pathological liar well it seems like
there's nothing like you said there
their character is deficient there's
nothing like inside there's no bedrock
on which their reality is based so
everything is superficial everything is
geared toward manipulating other
people's perceptions yeah well once you
see it a couple times you're able to
recognize yeah I if you guys want to see
it go look at videos of Charles Niang
Ning and Leonard Lake yeah and you know
there's videos of them talking and they
were serial killers
both of them it's me the show about wait
that's the way they all feel they feel
fake if you you watch them they're
actually committing crimes or getting
ready to commit a crime
commit crimes they seem like they're
role-playing or like bad acting for like
a really low budget movie it doesn't
seem real because they're not real yeah
because like I said they don't seem to
have anything underlying like a really
bad cosplayer or like a cyborg yeah
never like or someone that's like an AI
yeah Graham
right and they're just trying to go
through the motion once you've seen a
couple of them you'll never forget it
and you can recognize it in other people
I've seen it a couple times so it should
be noted that even though Ted Bundy
recalls his own high school experience
as being oh I was a loner by my own
choice because I didn't know how people
made friends I didn't know how it worked
and bah blah blah when some of his
classmates from the time were
interviewed they said that he was a
pretty well-liked popular dude like not
the most popular but not unpopular
either like you know he they knew of him
yeah like he seemed pretty well-liked
and normal he was also kind of big into
skiing that was kind of his big although
the funny thing was that he got into
skiing by stealing ski equipment yeah
now he was also arrested twice when he
was in high school just for [ __ ] like
burglary auto theft and like I said
we've said this on other serial killer
shows too it does seem like they start
with real minor [ __ ] like that it's
usually peeping tom [ __ ] arson
you know just minor theft and then kind
of progresses later on into he like true
what they call preppy [ __ ] he likes
pretty [ __ ]
he even like wanted to be a Republican
he was a Republican yeah he did not
become revoked but yeah we didn't high
school he works for yeah yeah you know
he's trying to be as preppy as he could
and conservative and everything he was
into that yeah but like I said there was
just the appearance of the [ __ ] right
well like I said that seemed like the
most important thing like he almost
seemed like that was what he thought
people wanted
from him right or that was how he was
gonna fit in because that was something
that he used kinda to his advantage like
I said you know since the Netflix series
came out there was kind of a big you
know thing where Netflix was like please
stop talking about Ted Bundy's like oh
he's the hottest serial killer and all
this other kind of [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
which it is um you know one he wasn't
hot but he was an okay looking dude I
think that what happened with him was
that he was so normal-looking and so
seemingly normal acting that he was able
to and he knew that about himself yes so
that kind of facilitated a lot of the
[ __ ] that he got into later on because
he knew that oh I'm just a bland white
bread looking do you yeah when you back
up off of him and look at him he was a
skinny scraggly weakling really he was a
weak man and this was noted even by the
police who were interviewing him in
prison that that his reputation had kind
of like was built up and I wish they
would and and one of the guys that I
wrote that that I read I read a book um
said when he went to go interview him
and say he was impressed just how weak
he was physically weak and small yeah
and no it was not hot he was not hot
little scrawny weakling like I said he
just looks like an average white bread
type of dude which allowed him to get
away with a lot of [ __ ] because people
didn't think that people like that I
think they still kind of you know and
particularly back then in the 70s
you thought if someone was a [ __ ]
serial killer and a necrophile and stuff
like that they would look like a scumbag
and he doesn't look like a scumbag he
just like looks like a hand looks like a
weasel
he looks yeah but he doesn't like stand
out no is what I'm saying he doesn't
look he doesn't I'm horned it doesn't
look like a [ __ ] monster or anything
like that he just looks like a regular
frat bro that you'd see like that you'd
kind of push off you in a bar you know
what I mean he just looks like that like
relatively normal I don't think so I
think he looked he I think that I think
the average frat bro actually was a lot
more competent looking than
he was he was kind of wormy and weaselly
yeah in person really so like I said he
did commit some [ __ ] minor crimes and
he was in high school but then you know
so he graduates high school in 1965 and
then he goes to University of Puget
Sound for a little while and then he
transferred to the University of
Washington to study Chinese now while
he's there he meets this woman um I'm
not sure what her real name is I don't
think they've ever given out her real
name because she's probably like hey I
don't want to be known as Ted Bundy's
ex-girlfriend in perpetuity let's like
you know use a pseudonym she's usually
given the pseudonym Stephanie Brooks so
he meets her and they started romantic
involvement now she was kind of
everything that he wasn't she was very
intelligent she was very beautiful she
came from like a really wealthy family
like she was going places um so they
went out for a while now Ted Bundy
actually only went to college for a
little while then he dropped out and
then started working you know he took
some minimum-wage jobs like just kind of
shitty ass jobs and then he started
volunteering for various Republican
politicians kind of trying to get it
over there but evidently his girlfriend
thought that he lacked ambition he
wasn't going anywhere in his life like
he was lazy and she just didn't think
anything was gonna come of it
she was right so yeah girl so you know
so she dumped him yeah now later on this
event is kind of and I'm not sure like I
said it's easy to kind of armchair
quarterback and like you know the next
you know after all the shit's happened
got to go back into sort of pivotal
developments in the guy's life and say
but this does seem to have made a very
large impact on him like his girlfriend
dumping him yeah a damaged because he
wasn't good enough yeah it devastated it
because I read a whole book you know the
book that I read on there said that this
is the pivotal moment in this losers
life
yeah when this girl dumped him he was
[ __ ] over alright he's [ __ ] up and
really he based his entire victim
profile on this woman yeah yeah
yeah because a lot of his later victims
did look very much like her as a lot of
his biographers it was killing this one
in effigy over and over again it does
seem like that but you because his
personality type was very much of that
like I said he was very much into I want
to be accepted by people so I'm gonna
put up this veneer of what I think
people want and then when that is
rejected by someone with greater social
status she definitely did have net seems
to me he gets her back with the express
purpose of dumping her in order to
punish her he did do that
yeah that was his only way of striking
back yeah now some biographers have said
too that it might have been around this
same time that this girl dumped him that
he found out about his actual parentage
that his grandparents were actually like
I said it's right sure but some
biographers have thought that this might
have been when he put it so those two
things like happening in tandem the guy
I read agreed with that might have been
yeah around that time and it put him in
a big identity crisis right right right
yeah it's not a sin women were just
[ __ ] they lied to you there's [ __ ]
they need to be punished they're bad
yeah because I mean that makes sense
because not only did the girlfriend
dumped him but also he's like oh my mom
mother reject me didn't want to come
claim me and this and that and they just
liars and yeah it's all fake and these
[ __ ] need to be punished yeah that's
the mentality a lot of these guys have
yeah and it definitely does seem that he
know that so after that happened like he
moved around some um you know he kind of
went to Colorado he went here they're in
the other place and then he kind of
comes back to Washington in 1969 and
there he meets Elizabeth Klett fur now
they were actually in a relationship for
a very long time and she actually later
on kind of tried to report him to police
several times yeah but yeah so that is
actually her real name she went under a
pseudonym for a long time but they
actually came
what her real name was so then it seems
like after he met her and they kind of
got into a relationship then Bundy
decides okay I'm or you know you know I
guess maybe sort of superficially he's
like okay well I'm gonna get my [ __ ]
together and he goes back to college at
the University of Washington and he
enrolls as a psychology major
now with this he's actually very good he
excels at this like all his professors
love him he's doing great blah blah blah
um you know and he was an honor student
he got really good grades so he was good
at psychology cuz I guess he was messed
up so so he could like relate I don't
know but he was good at it anyway so he
started doing that like I said he
started getting more into politics and
things like that so he looked like he
was getting his life together
he also started volunteering this is
[ __ ] up this this part [ __ ] smoke this
[ __ ] me up he also started volunteering
for a suicide hotline crisis center um
you know we're people who were gonna
kill themselves like call in like asking
for help and like asking to be talked
out of it and this [ __ ] worked
there yeah
now and rule who she had worked for the
Seattle police permit she also worked
there later became a very very famous
crime writer probably one of the
best-known primaries in the u.s. she
knew him you know during this time cuz
she worked there as well and she said
she had no idea yes like he seemed very
kind very empathetic
I remember this at this point in his
life though I really think he was trying
to make something out of himself it did
seem to be yeah but it just wasn't
possible with the hand that he was dealt
he couldn't hold that facade together
that's not who he really was
yeah he was the kind of guy to take the
easy path and to go directed for like
direct gratification yeah so he couldn't
maintain this for very long from what I
remember that very quickly starts
committing his first crimes yeah it
actually wasn't long after this yeah
actually like I said there's some
controversy about when his crime started
because some biographers have said that
he might have killed a little girl
when he was 14 like in 1961 cuz there
was a crime that happened around that
sound like a girl went missing and that
sounds about right compared to what
happened with other offenders right baby
right he might be in a time where he's
trying to leave all that behind him he's
trying to become something I but they
just can't hold it together that's not
who they are
it doesn't feel right to them yeah so
you know because like you said it
doesn't come naturally
yeah that's not that's an artisan who I
am I just want to kill a [ __ ] and
that's you know that's what they go
that's and it's just too hard it's too
hard yeah and that's probably what
happened here you in a way I feel like
he was probably doomed yeah from the
start you know not and I'm not saying
that is any sympathetic toward him
because of Bad Brains
yeah so yeah so like I said he's working
as a crisis center and rule works there
she even wrote a book about him later
called the stranger beside me she said
he seemed like a totally normal guy who
was really good at his job and all this
other stuff so he graduates with a
degree in psychology in 1972 and then he
starts getting back into politics and
you know working for all these
Republican senators and whatnot gotten a
little bit of hot water when for one
particular campaign he actually was
posing as a student or a journalist or
something like that on the opponents you
know campaign trail and actually was
like recording everything the guy said
and although he was a plan yeah so you
know all that kind of stuff so he did
all that kind of [ __ ] and like I said
but a lot of the politicians that he
works for um they thought that he was
actually really smart that he was really
going places that he was going to be
successful one day so when he said hey I
want to go to law school they all wrote
him you know letters of recommendation
even though he did really shitty on the
admittance test its superficially
speaking it yeah he's making it so
attending to be so they let him in to
the loss into law school on these
recommendations because like I said he
did shitty yeah but like I said when he
got into law school actually and started
taking the classes they were too hard
for him
he couldn't yeah he couldn't do it he
found them like he said I find I found
them in comprehends yeah although you
know you can't associate this quality
with with just serial killers yeah a lot
of actual guys who end up being
politicians and presidents and Senators
have the same profile where they're
talking the talk they can't really walk
the walk well yeah they come from
wealthy families they act like there's
something and so they kind of become
something they're faking it until they
make it yeah a lot of them you know it
doesn't always work because sometimes
you get busted yeah but you know if you
ever see the movie Vice Dick Cheney and
you know George Bush and it's not just
Republicans you know it's the Democrats
too a lot of your a lot of your
political leaders don't come from much
really well yeah well being a politician
is all about telling people what they
were but they weren't like that you have
to be good at that type of [ __ ] floats
it floats to the top and if you're good
at like networking and stuff like that
you're gonna go you know go far today
because I'm not good at it but like
people that are good at even if they're
not good at anything else if they're
good at bullshitting then they will
probably get pretty far yeah yeah I mean
eventually they'll probably get caught
out maybe but a lot of times they don't
in the upper echelon it's a popularity
contest they don't care about too much
what year well they don't care what you
can actually do they hire people that
can do think that's their service
yeah you know I mean oh well why should
I worry about science I'll just buy some
scientists yeah why should I worry about
you know [ __ ] guys that are educated
I can I can buy those how they take by
these other guys that [ __ ] know how
to do so okay now at this point and this
is what you were mentioning before so in
1973 like Bundy goes on a trip to
California like for one of his
like a little political whatever's and
he gets back together with the ex
girlfriend Stephanie Brooks and she at
first is like super impressed like wow
you're like you're in high school you're
like you know doing all the stuff you
look like you're actually going
somewhere you look like you have your
[ __ ] together
and he's like yeah totally so they start
going out um he was also dating
Elizabeth Clifford but at the time in
you know the other state in Washington
State neither of them knew about each
other so he was keeping that [ __ ] going
to and maybe he might have had a bunch
of other [ __ ] going on to with other
women that didn't know about each other
so he is they think that he might have
been leading Stephanie along to get back
at her because he was basically super
affectionate oh we're gonna get married
this that and the other thing and then
he lets it go on for a while and then
suddenly he calls her or he just ghosts
her very much
and she calls him she's like what the
[ __ ] bro and he was like I don't know
you're talking about Stephanie we see
what he what happened was is that he was
pussy-whipped you know I mean she kicked
him to the curb used pussy-whipped
and he was embarrassed about it all
right and he fell so he so he tried to
rebuild himself into it you know I mean
into what he considered to be her ideal
man yeah so he could get her back all
right
and instead of being [ __ ] with he's
gonna whip to [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
[ __ ] you I don't watch you yeah that's
that's right it's like exactly what he
did right and she kind of figured that
out later she's like oh yeah yeah yeah
just God was getting revenge on me and
at a higher level he said you know in
not only her it's all of them yeah
and so that actor this actually helped
him gravitate towards killing these
women yeah I'm just gonna screw him and
kill him unless I hate a more yeah maybe
he did he may have killed that one a
long time ago and had like trying to
break the habit and it was still kind of
calling him yeah you know I mean and
that may of what caused his facade to
fall apart now this isn't Who I am
yeah you know this is too difficult I'm
just gonna kill people like I wanna kill
kill him yeah you know I mean these
women are bad we'll kill him like you
said it's it's just
like somebody that has a particular
predisposition toward whatever it is
yeah and they're trying and they know
it's bad and they're trying not to do it
but then they're just like [ __ ] it it's
like a gay guy trying to live the
straight life he might be a guy saying
that I'm just saying you know serial
killing
alright serial murder is a sexual
orientation really when you look at it
it's kind of like there are gay guys
that try to live a straight life it just
they just can't do it it's a man so
falls apart and they go back to being
gay and that's that's probably what
bundy was about his sexual orientation
was to be a killer you know and then be
a serial killer
he tried to be something better in
society but that's not who he was he was
serial killer yeah now he did say like
he did admit later on to a biographer
it's like I just wanted to prove that I
could have married her if I wanted to
look that I was good enough he didn't
say that but that was the implication
that's the same thing I just told ya he
did say it like that and like I said she
did seem to figure that out later on
it's like oh that's why he pulled that
kind of [ __ ] now it was around this time
he's an [ __ ]
yeah well that um you know like I said
he started skipping classes at lost gold
later he would drop out um and also at
this stage women in the area started to
disappear so that's awful strange
yeah started disappearing around the
time he dumps her I'm telling you yeah
and like a union and like I said now
they they don't know cuz he might have
killed some people earlier but this is
kind of when because his serial killing
career is usually put between 1974 and
1978 even though there might have been
some earlier might have been one as
early as 1961 when he was still a
teenager but they can't prove it that's
typical for though for them yeah is they
kill one when they're young and then
they stop right or they continue to get
caught early but usually what they do is
they kill one early stop yeah for a long
time yeah cuz it bothers them but they
get keeps calling them back to do it and
then in their 20s or 30s they get caught
yeah that's so they're probably right I
might agree with him because like I said
now he later on but told cuz like I said
biographers many journalists like
interviewed him and he would tell them
different things now one person he told
that oh well the first time I tried to
kidnap a woman was in 1969 in New Jersey
but my first killing wasn't until 1971
okay um he uh but then he told somebody
else that in 1969 he had picked up two
women in Atlantic City and killed them
although he didn't name them he didn't
say who they were um and he also said
that he murdered somebody in Seattle
he said he Mert in 1972 he also said he
murdered somebody in 1973 like a
hitchhiker a girl that was hitchhiking
so and like I said there was the one in
1961 which was an eight year old girl
named Ann Marie burr so they think that
he might have been involved in that too
and that might look back then he was
only 14 years old so yet even at 14 he
should have been eight that sounds about
right yeah with the other ones that I
know of that killed him when they were
about that age they usually go after a
little girl yeah and then they deny it
they try to attend like they didn't do
it then they try to forget it yeah but
then later on in life they go back to
that kind of stuff we get with an older
victim I would think that you're that
they're probably right that he killed
that eight-year-old girl when he was a
little kid and then he tried to forget
about it yeah I think so and it wouldn't
surprise me if he had killed other
people too like leading up to this could
be could be but it would also it would
also wouldn't surprise me if he's lying
about that yeah that's what it is
there's no way [ __ ] lie because he
told different people different things
so there's no way of really sorting that
means dead now taking taking what I know
of him and the other ones I would think
based on the other cases most likely he
probably did kill that little
eight-year-old girl when he was 12
yeah and then and that he probably
didn't kill those other ones is that you
know I mean that it's more along the
official timeline of the provable bodies
and you know and it was after he after
he dumped that girl that girlfriend yeah
okay because it does seem like that was
that would have been a trigger
canonical yeah canonical the canon is
probably correct yeah I would add that 8
year old girl yeah so like I said that
was when he was 14
now the canonical series of murders like
I said 1974 to 1978 now in 1974 Ted was
27 years old so they think that that was
when this particular series started now
in night in January of 1974 and this was
right around the time that he had dumped
that girl he supposedly breaks into the
apartment of this girl named Karen
sparks as she was only 18 and she was a
student at the University of Washington
she was a dancer and he took a metal rod
off her bed frame and sexually assaulted
her with it and then which gave her like
really bad internal injuries now she
survived although she had permanent
physical and mental disabilities yeah so
that they think was his first victim of
this particular series whether or not he
killed people for that they're not
entirely sure the next one he left her
for dead and she lived yeah why did she
testify against him I'm not I don't know
okay I don't know yes so maybe she
couldn't ID him that's what I mean I cuz
that's the thing like he would bust into
people's rut like brooms while they were
sleeping and [ __ ] like that because it's
so long since I've read the book about
it I forgot the cannon but you know I
remember in general yeah and then what
he did during the escapes you know after
his arrest and then so the next one at
the next attack after that happened like
less than a month later it's happened in
February February 1st 1974 again he
breaks into a basement apartment this
time it was another University of
Washington student named Linda and Healy
now she actually worked as she worked on
the radio like she would give the ski
report like every day so she had to get
up at like 5:30 and go in and give the
ski report um and one morning she didn't
show up and they wondered where she was
in ball of law so he actually kidnapped
her from
the house because when they went to the
apartment to find her they didn't see
anything amiss but then when they pulled
back the covers that was like blood on
the mattress and stuff like that he
evidently beat her while she was
sleeping
dressed her and then you know kidnapped
heard them like took her out of the
place so he didn't kill her there he
killed her somewhere yeah he took her
somewhere else and killed her he he did
that quite a bit he would usually take
them quite a distance before he did he
went to her um its it was usually the
same thing he would usually sexually
assault them then he would usually
strangle them I'm Tom why yeah yeah he
would either bury them dumped him in a
river
he liked to this is horrible but um he
liked to leave them like out in the
wooden stuff so he could revisit them
yeah you know it was kind of like
Ridgeway he'd go back yeah he's like a
necrophile and was free yeah like from
like you said when we talked about the
other show that's weird yeah yeah he
would like leave them until they were
like 2 brought in then I would go back
yeah they asked ridgeway's why did you
do that he was it was free yeah what
that's right that's the same kind of
[ __ ] all right yeah so he would sing
kind of thing that he would do here so
at this stage like I said you know the
first six months of 1974 you girls are
disappearing you know from this area
like one a month you know what I mean
and they didn't find some of them till
later on so the next one happens March
12th and this was Donna Manson she was
19 she was actually a student at
Evergreen State College in Olympia and
she was actually she just left her dorm
room like going to a concert or
something like that like at another
building on campus and disappeared and
they didn't find her till later on
another one disappeared April 17th a
girl named Susan Rancourt and she was
you know same kind of thing she was
going from like a meeting and she was
going back to her dorm room also
disappeared now interestingly when her
the report of her vanishing life was on
the news and stuff like that two other
girls who were students at the same
college this was actually Central
Washington State College
Ellensburg and they came forward and
said you know it's like that same night
like one of them said the same night and
one of them said like three nights
before they said this guy came up to us
and he was wearing a sling on his arm
like his arm was broken and he said he
had like a bunch of books and could we
help him carry them to his car so even
like that far back people were reporting
this particular behavior because that
was something that he did a lot like
that's how he would learn people to his
car he was into the ruse yeah just like
it was just like in silence at the
Assizes where he had the broken arm or
whatever and he's trying to put the
couch in the van
yeah and he's like I'm like what Ted
would do is that he would take a tire
iron and he'd put it on top of like one
of the back tires of his VW bug and he'd
have a cast on and he in with books and
he'd ask some cute girl coming out of
college cuz you carry my books to the
car like yeah yeah sure he'd carry his
book to the car and and why she was
leaning over putting the books in the
back seat of the car he'd reach over
there on top of that tired you know and
grab the tire article BAM and knock her
in the back of the head and then just
throw her in there and usually put like
I said he'd usually put handcuffs on yes
well so even if they woke up they were
then even tell stories that you know
they'd wake up while he was driving and
they would just act like nothing had
ever happened because their their brains
would be so rattled you know like where
am I and he could tell him any old story
and they just kind of go along with it
well you wouldn't know would you because
that happens and you don't remember yeah
he said he hit one girl in the head she
just went on a whole different
conversation about other stuff and he
held a whole conversation with her yeah
yeah about an unrelated thing certain
yeah they don't know what happened it's
like if you just snuck up behind him
yeah last thing you know you were just
helping some poor guy with a broken arm
then all of a sudden you're in a car and
he could tell you anything you wouldn't
know that's [ __ ] up well yeah that's
what he would do like I said just like
in silent oh yeah um okay yeah so the
next one disappeared on May 6 like I
said one per month
there's disappearing pisser he was going
on going on like candy and he's just
like picking him up
like juban this kind of [ __ ] so the next
one was named Roberta parks killing all
human beings like it's nothing
yeah this was an Oregon State University
for sexual purposes yeah now she was
just like I said she was going like from
her dorm to the next dorm over like to
her friend's house they were gonna go
hang out or something like that she
never got there so she also disappeared
now at this stage um you know obviously
investigators in the area are getting
concerned because like all of these
people all these women are vanishing and
they don't really seem to have yes
there's a victim profile they're all
good-looking they're generally all
college students most of them have dark
hair parted in the middle long yeah
which there's the thing like a lot of
people have made much of that like oh
that looks like you know the girl that
broke up but then you're like he was
trying to but you know they common
haircut back then that's what I mean
like a lot of girls had that hair in the
70s like just straight because that that
was very stylish at the time so I don't
know how much stock on a place in that
yes Ted Bundy later said oh they were
just young attractive people it's like
other than that they didn't really have
much in common I just picked them you
know at random because they've happen
you just want to really look
good-looking and that was a girl's
haircut yeah so I don't know how much
stock we should place in the own dark
hair parted in the middle because like I
said a lot of girls had hair like that
back then
yeah later on when he got captured he's
making fun of other serial killers no
one he was trying to help the FBI
profile I mean talking about how they
were bottom feeders and he liked a feed
from the cream of the crop up top up top
yeah where all the good-looking girls
were you know he would never go go after
any hookers you know that was scumbag
stuff you know he was something else he
thought a lot of himself yeah clearly
and that was one thing that really
pissed me off about watching the Ted
Bundy tapes that one he thought he was
super smart and he wasn't you know - he
clearly thought he was the [ __ ] I was
like a real high-class aristocrat that
guy yeah it's like I don't
he's driving a VW bug back in a day when
that [ __ ] wasn't cool I'd love to have
UW bug now I would because that's a cool
classic car I've kicked that [ __ ] out
look like speed buggy or something but
back in those days we saw one the other
day that looked like it had big fenders
on it cool back they will be back yeah
whatever the hurt what was the Herbie's
number I can't but yeah we saw on the
other net employment but yeah so like I
said all right so the next disappearance
happened on June 1st and this was Brenda
ball she was also 22 she was actually in
a tavern called the flame tavern and she
was in the parking lot of the tavern and
numerous witnesses saw her talking to
somebody like a brown hair guy with his
arm in a sling so he was pulling that
cheap [ __ ] again yeah and then she also
vanished now only 10 days later a girl
named George Ian Hawkins who was also
another student at the University of
wash Washington
she was actually this one freaked me up
for some reason these all freaked me out
but this one freaked me out the most she
was going down she was going from her
boyfriend's dorm back to her sorority
house it was an alley it was like not
very long it was super brightly lit
everything like that
she disappeared somewhere in between
there yes so they so they look for her
they can't find anything now same thing
when her disappearance you know made the
news then some people came forward like
witnesses came forward and said that
this time the guy had brown hair this
time he had his leg in a cast and was
like walking on crutches and was trying
to carry like a suitcase or a briefcase
so that's how he was getting him this
time and another woman also came forward
and said yeah this guy came up to me and
said hey can you put the suitcase in my
car or whatever so he's basically like I
said so there's the thing again about
the victim profile because he had
obviously approached other women who
were like nah um you know what I mean
and told him to go away so he wasn't
like pick he was just picking whoever
happens by it seemed like whoever like
fell for his ruse and you know what I
mean as long as he liked her yeah
as long as they were like good-looking
well it's the way he is or he would just
go like I said he would just go to the
first good-looking girl yeah walk by and
be a little bit oh my poor leg is broken
can you please help me carry about yeah
so yeah now while he was doing while all
of this was going on like this six
months where all these women disappeared
um he was actually working for and this
is [ __ ] up too and I forgot to mention
also earlier that remember he was work
at the suicide hotline yeah when he was
working there he also wrote a rape
prevention brochure for women and I'm
like oh you can't make that [ __ ] up yeah
one of the things this yeah stay away
from me that was always I really wished
I we're from all this type of guys but
if you see a guy in a Volkswagen bug
with dark curly hair yeah he's cool to
go yeah what did that say but yeah so
during this whole time all these when we
were disappearing he was actually
working in the Department of Emergency
Services in Olympia which was helping to
look for them you know what I mean so he
was like right in the middle of action
yeah it seems like a lot of serial
killers have that too it's like you know
oh I want to keep up on like rise you
know how people are reacting to that
show well they're curious they're
curious to see how close they are to
being caught how much the authorities
know I mean you know they'll actually
volunteer to search for the bodies yeah
yeah I mean yeah you know when they have
the you know list we have to find
missing kaylynn or Kaling you're
socially Sally Sally's missing we're
gonna [ __ ] have them able to search
for him and that gal [ __ ] volunteer
yeah and talk to the cops and everything
yep you know and even talk to the news
media yeah we're out here trying to find
Sally yeah I've written about I've never
written about a lot of cases where a lot
of that shit's had like later on they
caught the guy they're like there he is
right there yeah it turned out he was on
the search party yeah he was he was
talking to the news and did news
interviews and that's that bits right
there yeah actually uh Charles Ryder yep
Charles Rader talking to the news him as
a dog catcher going we don't know what's
happening around him
I've got that little Charlie Raider
schedule with his fishnet stockings on
yeah down in that little hole yeah yeah
so kinky [ __ ] yeah but it's on a
man a man is killed somewhere in a
little dollies ass car yeah but you know
he was but he went out killing people
though Charles Raiders not that we know
if Charlie was thought he was a bandit
look I'm just gonna say this just just
now for the audience members there's
been all this who is the greatest serial
killer or who's the most frightening
serial killer and a lot of people would
say there was Ted Bundy but I'm gonna
say that now that shit's got to be
changing around I prize say this is
D'Angelo
I think D'Angelo would scare me the most
and these original nice dog we got away
with it for a long time law enforcement
training he was a booty commando he'd
come in on you he come in on couples
when the men were there yeah I would say
that that dude was the most direct in
terms of confrontation I mean he was a
booty warrior [ __ ] to have [ __ ]
man he's bad little dick though yeah
well all this like I said don't don't
talk about them in like admiring her I
would think now I was just thinking in
terms of like fear and threat I would
probably say D'Angelo was the biggest
threat yeah overall but like I said
because he was a threat to man - he's
the old [ __ ] now though yeah so he's not
threatening a [ __ ] he's an angry old
[ __ ] yeah well they are romantic admits
in the face I'm sure a lot of people
would like yeah you know but yeah so
around this time like I said not only
this [ __ ] working like in an
agency that was helping out with the
[ __ ] searches for all these poor
girls that had gone missing um he also
met around this time Carol Ann Boone who
later on she was actually one of his
biggest advocates she started he started
dating her like he was dating 50
bajillion other women at the time -
because that was how he was um but she
would actually end up marrying him lit
much later on and being his tireless
advocate and blah blah blah like she
thought he was in us
well until he finally confessed but
that's another story
so all right now I think at this point
we will probably take a break because
it's probably getting to sort of the
middle or whatever and then when we come
back we will talk more about the
murderers of Ted Bundy and how he got
caught his escapes and all that other
stuff so we will be back in just a few
minutes okay everybody ginnis got some
new shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out ready yeah
they're really good they're very high
quality shirts Jenny and I we're sure
our own shirts at certain times when
we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description
WWL calm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl calm / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cotton they look really cute JD's got
some so thank you go check them out
daddy's home
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format okay so the next one
the next disappearance that he
perpetrated actually happened on July
14th this is probably his most famous
one because it was two girls in one day
this happened at Lake Sammamish State
Park it was like a beach there very
popular there was a lot of people there
happened in broad daylight um so
evidently before he you know approached
the girls that would become his victims
he actually approached five other women
and he gave his name as Ted so he and
his face wasn't covered up for nothing
like that so he comes up to these people
and he's wearing a sling on his arm he
says his arm is broken he's like hey can
you come help me get this sailboat off
of my car four of them said no you know
I can't help you sorry dude the fifth
one actually kind of went with him to
his car but then saw that there wasn't a
sailboat on that took the [ __ ] off right
however the sailboat off my car you go
to the car there's no sailboat yes and
this guy supposed to be smart so yeah
now one other woman Janice OTT she was
20
three years old and he came up and asked
her and she was like okay fine and then
she disappeared now about four hours
later he didn't kidnapping them at the
same time it was just the same area four
hours later
um this 19 year old woman named Denise
Naslund she actually I I don't know if
he came up to her and lured her away she
just like she was there having a picnic
like with her boyfriend and some other
friends and she just left to like to go
to the bathroom and didn't come back so
you know that's how that happened no so
he kidnapped them both the same day now
he said later on like after he was
arrested he said that when he came back
with the second girl Denise that he
forced one of them to watch him rape and
kill the other one
yeah but then later on he said that he
hadn't done that so I don't know what
actually happened there that was
mentioned in a book that I read it yeah
that but he told like I said he told
different people different that
different things right so I don't really
didn't happen cuz I that would take a
lot of force and a lot of himmat
intimidation to get that to happen I
mean you'd have to have him almost
literally in a cell to get to yeah I
mean like I said he did usually knock
them unconscious he did usually restrain
them in some fashion um you know some of
the victims it looked like they'd been
alive for a while but most of them I
feel like he probably just kidnapped
them and then you know took them
somewhere else and then raped and killed
them pretty much immediately I was under
the impression that he didn't keep him
alive for long one of them they think
was maybe alive for seven days but
they're not entirely sure so I don't
know I I feel like most of the time he
probably just took them he would usually
take them quite far yeah because a lot
of the bodies were found like on a
hiking trail that he used to you know so
he would take them kind of far away
where he would do whatever and then
dispose of the bodies so like I said
since he had approached so many people
at this Park and so many people had seen
him they actually got a really good
description of him he had given his real
name not his last name obviously but he
told them that his name was Ted and he'd
been wearing an arms
so they got like a pretty good drawing
of him and they kind of you know and his
car and everything like that so they put
that out on the wire now it should be
noted that when this information went
public his girlfriend called the police
and really I know that mother who worked
and all who worked with him and later
became a crime writer she worked with
him at the suicide hotline she called
the police someone who worked with him
at the emergency services place called
the police one of the University of
Washington professors whose class he was
in called the police yeah for people
called the police yeah and said hey that
sounds just like a guy we know named Ted
Bundy he has a car just like that he
looks just like that you know and all
this other kind of [ __ ] yeah so now okay
I you know yeah I know hindsight's 20/20
blah blah blah like the police were
getting a lot of tips about this that
and the other [ __ ] everyday so
they weren't sure but I do feel like oh
he was a law student you know he doesn't
look like a killer he doesn't look like
you know what I mean yeah we're looking
for soon you have a record they were
looking for so many more like Richard
Ramirez right sue they were looking
that's what I mean so I feel like even
though several people reported him at
the time I feel like they were thought
no it can't be
it can't be that guy he just he looks so
normal he looks so clean and like I said
I feel like he used that to his
advantage like he knew that he could
blend in and like look like that now the
two girls that he kidnapped from the
park were actually found in September so
like a few months later like a couple of
hunters found the skeletal remains now
when they came and collected the
skeletal remains of those two girls they
also found an extra leg bone and like
another part of a backbone like from a
third victim yeah and at the time they
didn't know who that was now later on
when they got Ted in custody and they
made him like confess to all the stuff
he said oh that was George and Hawkins
like one of his earlier victims now
about six months after that they there
were some other there were these
students that were kind of out
this particular hiking trail and they
found a bunch of skulls of several of
his other victims like I think it was
four other ones yeah there was like up
on Taylor Mountain now a couple of the
people that he killed that went missing
around this time period have never been
found but most of the most of the
skeletal remains were found in this
particular area now after this like I
said this stuff all this was his Pacific
Northwest period um after this in about
August of 1974 he actually got a second
acceptance to the University of Utah law
school and just as before he started
taking law school again and even though
he had taken some of the classes before
he still was like I have no idea of what
um but he did move to Salt Lake City
yeah a [ __ ] even did homework I don't
think he did no yeah um but yeah and
like I said he wasn't as nearly as far
as he thought no so he moved to Salt
Lake City to go to college now his
girlfriend Elizabeth Klepper who like I
said she had reported him but obviously
didn't tell him that um and she didn't
know anything about all the other women
that he was dating at the time she
stayed in Seattle so you know so he
moved away blah blah blah now obviously
as soon as he moved to Utah then women
started disappearing and turning up
murdered there
September 2nd according to him he
actually picked up a hitchhiker and
raped and strangled her this was an
Idaho they never found that the remains
of that victim and then on October 2nd
was only a month later he actually
kidnapped a 16 year old girl called
Nancy Wilcox
and that was in a suburb of Salt Lake
City he said later on that he was trying
to when he took this girl he was just
gonna rape her and not kill her because
he was trying to quote-unquote
de-escalate okay yeah yeah which yeah
it's that's [ __ ] up it's almost like
an alcoholic saying well I'm just I'm
gonna work it down or like a smoother
saying I'm gonna work it down to a pack
a day
than half a packet yeah that's what it
sounds like he was talking about so he
tried he's so he's gonna try and do I'm
just gonna rape her I'm not gonna kill
this one however he said that she
started to scream and then he put his
hands around her to stop from screaming
and ended up killing her anyway
guarantee you it's all according to him
yes so like I said everything like take
everything he says with a grain of salt
because he is a big fat liar yeah um now
he said where he buried the remains but
so far they have not been able to find
them um okay so a little more than a
month later this is or actually a little
less than a month later October 18th
there's a little girl named Melissa
Smith she was 17 years old now she was
at her dad was actually the police chief
another suburb of Salt Lake City called
Midvale she was at a pizza restaurant
and she left and then disappeared about
a little more than a week later they
found her naked body in the mountains um
this is the one where they think she
might have been alive for a week after
she disappeared like he might have been
keeping her alive somewhere but they're
not entirely sure but usually they can
tell like when you know the date of
death was and stuff like that I wonder
where he would have kept it cuz based
based on my recollection to my reading
this is a long long time ago during this
period he mostly ran around shamon
pretending like he was going to school
not making much money and going through
panic attacks yeah I don't think he
would have had a place to take her
yeah yeah he was living on a shoestring
budget trying to keep up appearances you
know spending money on clothes he really
couldn't afford I mean really there's
really nothing to this guy's a bum yeah
basically a bum college student kind of
guy yeah so yeah I don't think he would
have had the money to take her anywhere
like I said that's why I kind of hate it
when they try to make more of him than
he actually was it's like yeah he was
good at blending in and being Trump
being slick and like people not
suspecting him yes he didn't look like a
serial killer if he kept her alive
anywhere just
would have been a situation like we kept
her alive chained to a tree or some real
low budget yeah there was really nothing
to this guy yeah so yeah so on Halloween
of that same year he kidnapped yet
another 17 year old girl who was also
leaving a restaurant
her name was Laura Amy and same kind of
thing later on her naked body was found
kind of in a mountainous area now both
of these women had been strangled to
death with a nylon stocking they had
obviously been raped and sodomized and
beaten severely and also at this point
Bundy did confess that these two
particular victims and probably most of
his other ones too as I said he would
return and revisit the bodies he would
also put makeup on them he would put
nail polish on them he would dress them
in particular ways he said something and
I'm paraphrasing here but he said
something to the effect of well you go
to all this trouble you know you you
want to like remember it or you want it
to be you want them to be the way you
want them you know what I mean so he
would like do their makeup and like
nails and dress them the way he wanted
them to look sex doll yeah and then you
would go back and rape their corpses
yeah pretty much
so yeah and he gets worse than yeah to
later on yeah cuz he would decapitate
him to just take the heads sometimes
yeah put that up in the refrigerator so
there was a lot of there's a lot to him
it's kind of more like Dahmer - yeah he
had a Dahmer like well and I feel like
that doesn't get across much meanness
when you're talking about necrophiliac
killers like everybody says you know
Dahmer and [ __ ] Dennis Nilsen and
those kind of but not many people bring
up Bundy even though he was a necrophile
- yeah I don't think he ate him no he
wasn't Anibal he would take although he
had set him up have six two heads and
they get an argument with a head slapped
a head and he was a [ __ ] loon
he was a [ __ ] lunatic yeah no [ __ ]
yeah people people don't [ __ ] realize
that he was a lot worse than people
think
yeah and like some of those girls the
young ones that he didn't want to take
credit for but they really think that he
did it one of them was some girls about
13 you took her to like an old
slaughterhouse where they used to
slaughter pigs and they found that girl
Connor in it with her throat cut on the
main slaughter House floor in that
abandoned slaughterhouse there and in a
position as if he had basically
slaughtered her like a pig
it's basically what it was he denied
doom but pretty much pretty much all the
law enforcement agents that asked him
about it and looked at that case they
think they're pretty sure he did that
[ __ ] because there was no other offender
in that area at that time
yeah you know and if there was another
offender than where are his other bodies
yeah he probably killed it was him yeah
more people than they know about well
they always noticed that he never - they
noticed that he never took
responsibility for any underage girls
yeah and there were underage girls that
were killed by his MO in his area in the
time that he was where he was and there
was no other serial killer captured yeah
it was him yeah it's like who the [ __ ]
else would it be
it was him he just didn't and even wrote
about a couple cases you know in my
unsolved murders books that they highly
highly like strongly suspect was
probably Ted Bundy but they just
couldn't prove it because it seemed very
much like something he would use him and
he was in the area at the time like
there was one in Burlington Vermont
where he was from and like show like
that he's just trying to disassociate
himself from that aspect of his crimes
free yeah because he was trying to look
like a man yeah you know he's a big
tough guy somehow all right oh I don't
go after little kids yeah you did yeah
yeah he did he tried to keep that secret
yeah even though like he admitted to
like horrible [ __ ] I don't know why he
didn't just go whole hog because he
didn't want to admit that he went after
little girls I guess all right so the
next thing that happened now this girl
acts
she got away so and she if you see she's
on Ted Bundy tape she's on pretty much
all the Ted Bundy
you know documentaries like talking
about her escape so she was eighteen
years old at the time her name is Carol
de ranch this happened on November 8th
and she was at Fashion Place Mall and
Ted comes up to her and says his name is
officer Roseland and that somebody had
broken into her car and she had to come
with him and see if anything had been
stolen right so she's like okay fair
enough so she goes out there and then
she starts to get skeeved out because
here's one interesting thing that I
found about the Ted Bundy tapes is that
it was almost all dudes that we're
talking about how charming and [ __ ] he
was not women it seemed like most of the
women on their cream yeah like you know
dudes might have a very good creepy very
good detector and most women are pretty
good at that um so she wanted women knew
that he was a creep
Jenna and I were on our little path
doing our walk we talking about the debt
that judge that sentenced him to death
and [ __ ] yeah and I was just outraged of
what that judge can't believe that
[ __ ] dude sent me and I mean and I
believe that and I I kind of think it
wasn't a dude thing I think it was a
generational thing yeah cuz that guy you
know he that judge is long dead now you
know I don't even think he was a baby
boomer he was all it was too old to be a
baby boomer but there was something
about that generation of men they were
very dumb very dense ya know I mean I
think they were just kind of very late
be snowed pretty yeah you could snow him
easy advice by Slick wise and
superficial [ __ ] that that they were
used to seeing in their cultural milieu
you know I think that's what it was kind
of what it was yeah because he was
saying silly [ __ ] like oh what a waste
and you would have another you're you
know you're a good dude and you know
this you come to this and I don't have
anything again against you and it's just
like it's like the there we're in the
bro clubs and you were almost a lawyer
severed hey yeah yeah
and there's something this judge just
this could didn't compute in this judges
[ __ ] head it made me hearing him say
that maybe one just jump up and slap
that [ __ ]
I want to slap that Judge bow dead dude
was [ __ ] severed heads cutting the
throats of [ __ ] thirteen-year-old
girls on the [ __ ] slaughterhouse
floor [ __ ] paying slaughterhouses
like who and your your teen you don't
have anything against him what kind of
man are you kind of funny I would
seriously watch that and my jaw dropped
again what do you say that I'm like um
not know if I can kidding me with that
yeah now we're gonna go back to what I
said about lawyers you know I don't want
to [ __ ] [ __ ] on lawyers but cops
judge me judges are lawyers and there's
something about [ __ ] people that want
to get into the into the law profession
they're just some about them I don't
trust them just saying yeah sometimes
when I hear they said well we're gonna
have to worry about the rule of law I
immediately started getting very
suspicious because that means oh you
listen to those [ __ ] the DD role
players you don't I mean the guys are
just wordsmith [ __ ] and try to [ __ ]
get you to go along with them based on
the way they way they word things in
their narrative you know and guys that
don't really believe too much in writing
law right and wrong more about how they
describe something more than anything
else and how it falls among inside these
books that they collect and they were
written by other guys who were just like
them [ __ ] twenty thirty forty years
and years ago 200 years ago I'm very
skeptical that [ __ ] cuz it just looks to
me so much like the priest class and the
[ __ ] and religion is what it looks
like to me yeah you know I'm just saying
I'm going off on a tangent were talking
about just the law profession to me
looks a lot like a religion just saying
yeah it's like the holy books it's like
you know I mean the holy books and the
law books yeah
okay so Carroll de raunch like I said he
comes in the mall and he says somebody
broke in your car I have to take you
down to the station you have to like
file a report or whatever so she gets in
the car and then he starts driving in a
direction which is not toward the police
stations she's like what the hell this
isn't where the police station is
and then he starts like struggling with
her and he starts to he tries to put the
handcuffs on her but because she's
struggling so much he ends up putting
both of them on the same wrist so she
jumps out the [ __ ] car and she gets
away now later on that same day so
evidently Ted was pissed off that this
girl had escaped so he decides he's
gonna go pick up another one so the same
evening there's a girl named Deborah
Kent she was 17 years old she was
actually a high school student and she
was at like a theater like a play or
whatever at the school and she left
early because she had to go pick up her
brother from wherever he was and then
she ended up disappearing now later on
the drama teacher at the school and
another student came forward and said
that Ted they didn't know who it was at
the time but Ted had come up to them and
said hey why don't you come out to the
parking lot blah blah blah so they said
they saw the same guy he was like pacing
around the auditorium so he's been seen
by like multiple witnesses alright so
and then later on like outside this high
school they found a handcuff key and
they later matched it to the handcuffs
that were on Carol Durant so they know
that this is the same guy now after this
went public you know the [ __ ] was
happening in Salt Lake City so then his
girlfriend Elizabeth Klepper she calls
the cops again and reports Ted Bundy
again because she's like look he's in
Salt Lake City now he moved there this
is the same [ __ ] that's going on it
sounds like him blah blah blah please do
something about that but again they did
not so this is two times she's reported
it now two times so then January 12th
this actually happened in Colorado so
he's like kind of moving around a little
bit
this girl's 23 years old she was an RN
her name was Ken Karen Campbell and she
was this is creepy - she was at Wildwood
in like a resort and she was walking
from the elevator to her room like down
the hall and disappeared at some point
in between there so he got her yeah he
got her in between there welcome to our
an Astra question I gots Alcon to her
and then he talked to her she's never
talked to dude smack her in the [ __ ]
head of a something just you know
seriously I'm and I do this you you walk
anywhere and some dude is like hey can i
smoke nope no I'm not talking to you I'm
not getting close to you nothing I've
read too much of this [ __ ] I know it
happened but yeah so she was actually
her naked dead body was found about a
month later not that far from their
resort actually so then March 15th
another girl Julie Cunningham she was 26
she was actually a ski instructor and
then she also disappeared on the way to
a dinner date with a friend of hers so
this was the same kind of thing where he
came up to her he was wearing crutches
blah blah blah then he hit her over the
head and blah blah blah so um he did the
same thing with her he dumped her body
and then went later on and revisited as
they would say the next one to disappear
was Denise
Oliver since she was 25 disappeared near
the Utah Colorado border on April 6
small brighting her bicycle to her
parents house they actually found her
bike in her shoes underneath a railroad
bridge now here see here's another one
that Bundy never confess to but they're
pretty sure he did this May the 6th Ted
Bundy lured 12 year-old Lynette Culver
from a junior high school in Pocatello
Idaho and then apparently he took her to
his hotel room that he was staying in
where he sexually assaulted her and then
threw her body in a river although I
don't think her body has ever been found
but he did like they did later think
that that that was where she ended up
probably the Snake River but they're not
really sure so at this stage um Carolyn
yeah you could throw somebody in the
river and they never find him yeah
that's weird that's not that weird
rivers lead out to the ocean and if the
body gets swept out
we have this we have this like
assumption that everything is just based
on TVs and movies and just you know the
news that everything is wrapped up yeah
and every square inch of the country so
it could be you know kind of under
surveillance you can't get away with
anything you can throw something if I
can River well the sea is on either side
you never find look at all the people
that have like disappeared that they
never found there's thousands and
thousands of yeah I know it rationally
but it kind of shocks me that yeah you
could be so close to civilization and
dump something in a river then never
find a person yeah so okay so at this
point like I said you hit him and
Elizabeth clef are still together um
like I said I I think she suspected at
the time that he was probably the one
responsible for all this but maybe she
was kind of wasn't sure but they
actually kind of like he went to visit
her in Seattle and then they were kind
of talking about getting married even
though she at this point I think she had
reported in to police like two or three
times at this stage but of course she
didn't like tell him that so the next
woman to disappear was Susan Curtiss and
she vanished on June 28th from Brigham
Young University in Provo now this one
girl yeah well this was interesting too
because Ted Bundy was actually baptized
into the Mormon Church even though he
didn't like ever turn up to any of the
[ __ ] right he didn't like do any Mormon
he don't get some girls probably that's
what I mean it all seemed to be like
part of the facade as Ted Bundy he's
like oh well not only am I an upstanding
law student Republican now I'm gonna be
a Mormon - yeah justice Smith yes so
yeah so he did get baptized into the LDS
Church like I said he didn't show up or
anything but he was actually baptized
into the church because you know that's
an it's a gnostic a belief system it's
very like a cult
do you not I mean it's interesting yeah
I don't know so now at this stage I
think it finally cause like I said this
is the 70s you know they didn't have
computers and have internet
that [ __ ] you know everything had to be
done by hand or just like over the phone
so it took them a really long time to
realize that the all this [ __ ] that was
happening in the Pacific Northwest was
maybe the same dude that was doing all
this [ __ ] in Utah
and some in Colorado but at this stage
it seems like they kind of realized that
this maybe was the same guy because the
description of the person in the
description of the car was very similar
the mo was very similar so they kind of
started setting everything up but like I
said you know they didn't have computers
or anything like that do everything by
hand they've pretty much had like all
these little lists of like dudes named
Ted you know dudes with tan Volkswagens
dudes with this then the other and they
had to like cross-reference you know
what I mean um so they had 26 suspects
that turned up on all of their
cross-reference list that all that had
all of the things that had been reported
Ted Bundy was on there and he was on
there like best suspects list but again
it seems like nothing was really done
much about it however Bundy was arrested
for the first time in August of 1975 and
he was arrested in Utah now he was
actually only arrested at first because
um the cop like saw him kind of cruising
around and thought it was sort of
suspicious and plus they knew that you
know tan Volkswagen or brown Volkswagen
it was described different ways and he
thought it was suspicious and when he
went to pull him over
Ted like a dumbass took off and tried to
get away most had some in the damn car
well so finally the officer gets in to
pull over and then he looks into the car
and sees that the front passenger seat
is not in the car like it's been taken
off and it was in the back seat so
they're like oh that's a little weird
and then when they search the car again
they found [ __ ] like a ski mask a mask
made of panty hood like pantyhose with
eyes cut out
yeah he's crowbar it was pretty much hey
serial killer murder kid like right
there in the [ __ ] car when I use a
kick when I was a kid they had these
magazines they were like true crime
magazines those [ __ ] things they stood
out and then the cover was always some
dude with the damn ski mask with the
eyes cut out and all that and the women
screaming in the telephone man and I
think serial killers the read that [ __ ]
you see probably did you see you in the
newsstand
like I said Bundy kind of like told one
biographer that he was super into those
but that but then later on told another
one it's like I would never
he probably [ __ ] because you may be
next to all the other stuff like guns
and ammo and I'd look at that joke it
was a true detective yeah something some
[ __ ] like that yeah throw you dump
through it and it almost looked like
like cheesecake yeah tight you know I'm
talking about and bondage yeah it's what
it looked like it was it was like almost
like a legal way to get bondage yes the
censors oh we're talking about a crime
yeah so it's totally for yeah it's not
for sexual gratification no these hot
models all tie that [ __ ] look at the
camera yeah I'm gonna get a knife coming
down yeah [ __ ] yeah so I I kind of feel
like yeah he was in Tibet so they found
all this [ __ ] in this car Bundy tries to
explain it away like oh well the ski
mask is cuz I ski and the rest of the
[ __ ] I found in a dumpster I don't know
what you're talking about I'm not a
burglar or murder or anything but the
cop at least had the presence of mind to
go hey this is a tan folks wagon Hey the
person that kidnapped Carroll de ranch
like I said she got away described a car
very much like this described a dude
that looks very much like this so let's
take this guy and so also then later
they got a warrant to search his
apartment and they found a kind of a
guide to the ski resorts in the Colorado
area and like a dumbass he had put a
check mark next to the Wildwood Inn
which is where he kidnapped one of his
victims from he also had a brochure from
the high school play where he had
kidnapped one of the other victims so
you know he's like I said he's not the
sharpest knife in the drawer yeah so
they kind of were like okay well you're
under arrest so they put him actually at
first they put him under surveillance
and then they questioned his girlfriend
and she
he told them that after he had moved
away she like found some weird [ __ ] in
the house like she's like I don't know
why he had like all his plaster of Paris
and like crutches and [ __ ] like that
because like he didn't break any bones
so that was kind of weird so she said
that said he had a um that he had a meat
cleaver in the house for some reason
that he never used for anything or so he
said and he had like a sack full of
women's clothes and stuff like that so
all this kind of stuff now she also said
that at one point she had confronted him
about a bunch of [ __ ] that he stole
because apparently everything that he
had in his apartment like all his
expensive [ __ ] um he had stolen
everything cuz he didn't owe any money
you know so she asked me without that
and allegedly he said to her you know
don't tell anyone or I'll break your
[ __ ] neck so there you go
now at this stage the police impounded
Ted's Volkswagen Beetle which he had
previous to this sold to someone else
but obviously they had record of that so
they went to this other person that he
told it to and they impounded it now
inside this car they found hair that
matched two of the murder victims and
also matched Carroll the raunch the 18
year old girl that had got away that he
had tried to kidnap now they didn't have
enough evidence at the time to charge
him with any murders although they
suspected him in many and like I said
the Pacific Northwest
cops were also thinking that uh you know
that he probably did that [ __ ] too
but they said well we have enough to
charge him with the Carroll to ranch
aggravated kidnapping criminal assault
so we're gonna charge him with that um
so that was the first thing they tried
to do now they let him out on bail and
he went back to Seattle and stayed with
his girlfriend now he was put on trial
for the kidnapping in February of 1976
um he actually waived his right to a
jury trial but the trial itself only
lasted four days the judge actually
found him guilty and sentenced him to
one to 15 years so they were gonna put
him in Utah State Prison and then later
on they had they had gathered enough
to charge him with one of the murders
that of Karen Campbell so they were
going to put him on trial for that so
they transferred him to Aspen now when
they transferred him to Aspen he had
actually wanted to serve as his own
attorney which if you do that they
actually will not put like leg irons on
you and they will give you access to the
law library at the courthouse and Ted
Bundy obviously knew this so they take
him to Pitkin County Courthouse in Aspen
for the preliminary hearing he says I
want to go in the law library and do
some research on my case and then he
like kind of scoots behind a bookcase
and jumps out a second-floor window yeah
you'd never be able to do this under
normal circumstance but because he had
history of having some taken some law
they let him do it yeah yeah because he
could say hey I was a law student yeah I
want to represent myself and they're
just like okay fair enough
he used as opportunity to escape so yeah
and like I said I'm sure he knew you
know he was he wasn't dumb he wasn't as
smart as he thought but he wasn't stupid
so he did know that that would that's
how that would go down so he used that
to his advantage now I'm not sure how
much of this he planned I think at this
stage I think he just wanted to escape
cuz he just jumped out the window he
sprained his ankle when he links like I
said it was a second second-floor window
and then takes off into the [ __ ]
mountains yeah like Rambo like a Rambo
one like yeah he finds a cabin like he
steals food and clothes and stuff there
but then he just like kind of wanders
around up in the mountain he gets lost
he can't find his way back down to town
bob was just stupid as [ __ ] because he
found a cabin yeah and he just stayed
and they probably never would have cried
never would've caught him like I'm glad
I'm glad he was yeah I let it blow over
yeah yeah so you know he founded me was
weakest [ __ ] you know he couldn't make
yeah he'd like lost all this weight as
okay that's Rebeck ground he could you
know how to survive out there in that
cold weather no equipment so he finally
finally like makes it back then he
steals a car like by
Aspen Golf Course and then he had like
lost a bunch of weight again slept he
was really cool he didn't you know he
had a parka that he had stolen from
another cabin yeah reality settled in on
nature yeah yeah but he he was on the
lam for six days and then they caught
him again so you know at this stage you
know the you know the case against him
or building like I said they're trying
to you know get him for other murders
that they suspect him in and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
so the dumbass and and the thing is that
even though he was suspected in a [ __ ]
ton of crimes like I said in several
different states um none of the cases
against him were like super super firm
and like some of the researchers and
biographers and stuff like that later
we're like you know if he hadn't been
just so dead set on doing all these
escapes and [ __ ] like that and actually
hired a competent lawyer or had a lawyer
assigned to him that knew what he was
doing he might have gotten away with
[ __ ] yeah but because he thought he knew
better and he's like well I'm gonna
escape her I'm gonna represent myself
like he kind of ended up [ __ ] himself
in the ass in the end because he thought
he knew better they didn't have a good
case on him really yeah I mean yeah they
really didn't I mean later on they might
have but in these initial stages it just
like any a serial killer he escaped just
so he could kill again yes does goes up
crime spree yeah and really they convict
him on the [ __ ] that he did after he
escaped yeah having to do with some bite
marks see he left on a girl yeah that's
really what got him then damn bite marks
so yeah we're gonna talk about that bite
marks in a bit we're gonna get to that
because he's already escaped at this
point yeah well this is his first escape
yeah he's twice yeah so the second time
like as soon as they got him back in
custody he's like a little bit escaped
again and he did it's like as soon as he
gets back in jail it took him a little
while but it's like he actually had like
Caroline Boone and the other thing in
the floor the ceiling got out yeah some
other people that he knew like smuggling
in money for him and he got like a
hacksaw blade and all this other kind of
[ __ ] he lost 35 pounds and he was pretty
much able it was like the Christmas
holiday like you know the prison was
short-staffed
whatever and he knew that the warden or
whoever like he knew that where his
apartment was he had a map of the prison
he got like you know through underhanded
means and he knew that that guy was
gonna be out so he basically lost so
much weight that he was able to wriggle
up through the ceiling and get out and
he like left books and [ __ ] in his bed
so it looked like he was still in there
and he crawled out the [ __ ] ceiling
and got away again
yeah so by the time they discovered and
you know he wriggled up into the wardens
apartment didn't he and then just like
yeah walks out the prison walked out
lucky we might ask well why you know if
he could escape why aren't there more
escapes and really if you kind of
research this you know aspect of
criminology you're gonna find out that a
lot of criminals don't want to escape
you think what do you mean that I want
to escape especially where it when
they're in the jail phase when they're
awaiting some kind of a trial their
crimes and the punishment they're gonna
get really isn't worth running from you
know I mean like a lot of them really
face in a few years so they'd rather sit
there and get credit for time served go
through the court process and then by
the time they get through the courts and
they go to the penitentiary they might
only have 12 months left okay and then
they do their 12 months and then they're
home free they're free they go out they
week job try to escape if you're on the
skin.you Runner forever you're gonna get
caught or shot or two you know if you
get caught then they'll add more time on
to your sentence and it's when you're
running you're running forever
you can't live a normal life yeah you're
always so there's no real there's no
reason to run from say a 5 or a 10 or a
15 year sentence you can be running for
the rest of your life it's better
especially when they're a young man at
most these guys are young it's better to
do that [ __ ] you know just do it yeah
you do the crime do the time to get out
because then you'll get out because
you'll spend the rest of your life
running and you'll never be able to have
a bank account or buy anything you can't
run from computers yes especially not
nowadays so a lot of them don't really
want to escape the biggest flight risks
or escape risks or guys that are facing
30 years 40 years life sentence death
they feel like they don't have anything
they God no no lose right right
yeah it's just some minor [ __ ] yeah most
of those guys in most of those guys in
jail are facing you know a waiting trial
they're not facing that much but you
know you and your guy like Bundy you're
facing the needle deaths it actually the
electric chair the electric chair so so
yeah that's why he ran time but was the
electric chair which state of Florida
that's where he was executed we should
lovingly call old Sparky yeah so he
found out he's found a weakness in the
in the prison cell and found that he can
go up through a little ventilation shaft
yes so he gets out yeah and they didn't
even like know where the [ __ ] it was
like he gets out he steals a car the car
breaks down he hitchhikes somebody picks
him up in and gave him a ride to Vail
Colorado then he gets on a bus he takes
a bus to Denver then gets on a plane and
goes to Chicago and then he like fake
[ __ ] takes a train to Ann Arbor
Michigan
and then he goes to Florida now in
Florida because like I said this was the
70s they didn't have computers and [ __ ]
like that you could just go around
willy-nilly um he actually rented an
apartment in Tallahassee near the
Florida State University campus and he
rented on her fake name Chris Hagen
evidently nobody asked for any ID or
anything like that so he rented a room
at a boarding house and he said he later
on he told biographers he's like oh well
after my escape to Florida because I
knew that you know it was Utah it was
Pacific Northwest if I kept my head down
in Florida they'd never catch me because
they would never relate like I said they
didn't have computers and everything
like that if you just had a fake name
and he's like so if I got a legitimate
job and just had a normal life they
would never catch me and I was good with
it this was in the nineteen seventy
eight yeah seven in the 70s the world
would have seemed that way that's what I
mean he thought he would just get away
he would just like disappear and he
would have disappeared for a while
but had went as soon as the 90 started
rolling
and he would have been caught yeah
because you needed a lot of ID by the
time the 90 started to roll around where
are you what is your ID yeah yeah you
couldn't run well and and it seems that
he kind of got in trouble with this even
in the 1970s because even though he was
able to rent a room like in a boarding
house under a fake name and he said and
like I said take everything he says with
a grain of salt he's a big fat liar but
he said that he was gonna try and find a
legitimate job so he went to a
construction site and he said that he
applied for a job there but they asked
for ID so he was like oh never I'll go
home and get it then he never went back
yeah and then he didn't apparently look
for any more jobs after that and then he
just started doing like he did before
like he would steal stuff like he would
go and [ __ ] stores and it's like if a
woman like left her purse and a shopping
cart or something he would just take her
walk like a shit-ton of like stolen
credit he went into vampire mode he just
kills you takes your [ __ ] and then just
spend some [ __ ] yes like I said he just
yeah he just would just go around and
like just take people's stuff when they
arrested him he found like they found
like a shit-ton he had like all these
stolen credit cards that's how he lived
cuz he didn't have a job or nothing yeah
so that's how we got her on the country
which is not fought to mode yeah which
like I said you couldn't get away with
that [ __ ] either
yeah and back then you would have been
burning the candle at both ends it would
be only be a matter of time yeah yeah so
and then this and like I said this is
the part that that I always remember
hearing about it because I've you know I
was born in Florida I grew up in Florida
so this was kind of like that the end of
his reign of terror was kind of like the
biggest deal for us because you know we
it was close by so January 15th 1978
he's only been in Tallahassee for like a
[ __ ] week right and apparently like I
said oh I tried to find a job oh I tried
to do this is that I tried to go
straight ya know so he walks into the
Chie Omega sorority I still don't
understand this go ahead go ahead I know
the lordís State University like the the
back door was apparently the lock was
broken or whatever so I don't know if he
knew that ahead of time or
whatever repeats been staking the place
out so he just waltzes into this
sorority house at 2:45 in the morning
yeah
walks into the room of Margaret Bowman
who was 21 years old just started
beating her in the head with it like a
big blob yeah and he found out back when
he went in and then strangled her with a
nylon style yeah raping him
yeah he then I don't know if he raped
her but he did for sure rape the next
one um then he did that then he goes
into another room yeah a 20 year old
girl named Lisa levy beat her
unconscious strangled her tore one of
her nipples almost off yeah bit her on
the butt yeah and then takes like a
bottle of like hairspray or something
suck it up her vagina yeah I come in a
sorority house there are like other
people yeah and here was the thing I
remember from reading about this he
walks in the back and one of the details
that wasn't mentioned wasn't mentioned
didn't that documentary and he didn't
mention it maybe it's not true but it
was in the book that I read he said hi
to somebody in the hallway he might have
because there a guy comes out that
sounds like some shitty would do because
yeah exactly
because the girls were all dating these
different guys and they were coming in
and out and he saw God and always hey
what's up man and then just went in the
other girl's husband because that was
kind of like you know there were guys
coming and going yeah I just happened to
be just one of them that's what I mean
no one would have like right thought
anything about and I don't remember how
many of them did he actually kill two of
them and then he attacked two more but
they survived okay so it was four yeah
total I can't understand how dude have a
sex drive to get four and it didn't take
long yeah they no way there's four
attacks happened in under 15 minutes
yeah that was some weird [ __ ] because
maybe I guess you just got to be in a
goddamn frame it was a frenzy that's you
know she's gonna say that's exactly the
word I was gonna
right that that really seems like what
this was he just walks into this place
like I said he killed the first two
women and then he goes the next bedroom
over beats the [ __ ] out of this other
girl named Cathy kleiner her he broke
her jaw and cut her shoulders all up
then there was another woman in Karen
Chandler she also got a broken jaw
concussion she he knocked her teeth out
crushed her hand um so they didn't see
anything they just woke up and saw I
mean like I said it was a middle it was
three o'clock in the morning so they
just woke up and see this dude like
above them with a club and all of a
sudden he's like knocking them in the
[ __ ] yeah so you gotta imagine this is
this is like a cross between blood lust
and sex drive and I'm just trying to
imagine man I can't understand how a man
could just [ __ ] keep going yeah I try
to put myself you know just in a regular
straight male normal heterosexual type
mentality and they say if I was single
yeah I mean then you lined up a bunch of
women I would think mmm
by the time by the time the second one
came around I'd be tired you guys go on
without me even if you well he was like
under 3730
I think even bags that even even was a
little bit older yeah he was early
thirties you gotta be I don't know man
he's unusual well he's it was before
viagra and like I said I don't these
ones he didn't run he didn't like rape
the one girl that he did sexually
assault it was with a bottle yeah I mean
the [ __ ] out of them okay although I
mean he raped most of the other ones
I thought sodomized yeah by memory I
thought he raped them all basically yeah
which you know that seconds almost like
superhuman endurance when you think
about it from a man's point of view I'm
like damn dude you know what's exciting
you so much about this situation you
know well that's what's the matter with
that
yeah that's not normal no no no not at
all that was just normal say
it takes about time second maybe you
might get to third when you were like
now I'm good I'll get you in a few
minutes yeah let me sleep for a bit yes
so and not only that so he attacks these
girls in this sorority house these women
in the sorority house kills two of them
horribly wounds two more then he just
casually strolls the [ __ ] out with his
[ __ ] log or whatever yeah then he
goes to another apartment yeah eight
blocks away from the sorority house and
there's another girl yeah yeah see that
was part of that was part of the tally
that I was thinking because I remember
that night that was kind of trying to
put myself into do the shoes thinking
man dude you know enough is enough I'm
saying you know what are you getting out
of this yeah now it's sex you know
they're rapists that's what these serial
killers are but it's got to be a kind of
situation where he's doing this [ __ ] at
this point out of spite because he knows
that his time is short so he's trying to
just increase the body count because
this song he does yeah this seems very
much like the final like paroxysm yeah
violence like they're right on my tail I
only have a few days I'm gonna knock
down because much as he later said oh
well I I felt like oh if I moved all the
way to Florida they never catch me in I
am believing as long as I stayed out of
the way the police and like kept my head
down and [ __ ] like that I feel like you
know how long did that last a week maybe
yeah and then he just total oh I'm gonna
attack five [ __ ] women in the same
[ __ ] night well all this stuff about
I'm gonna go to Florida and keep my head
down all right
that's probably just the [ __ ] that
he told the cops that's what I mean you
can't really what it was is like i'ma go
to [ __ ] Florida i'ma knock down as
many as [ __ ] that come fine that's
what he's thinking yeah and he honestly
as deluded as he was he probably thought
he could do that and he's like then I'll
just go to [ __ ] Note New Hampshire
something like like are you doing it
I'll just do it again yeah I'll run on
the brown
go through all 50 states he probably did
[ __ ] think that private is thinking
and he ended up like he ended up killing
or wounding women in what like seven
states or seven states where was it ten
I can't even remember it was like some
he's going after broke-ass college girls
so you can't even steal from him to
[ __ ] finance it's like an getting hell
out of there although like I said he's
he stole credit cards from other people
though he was like I said he stole them
he would go to a store like her a mall
and if a woman like left a purse yeah
like in a shopping cart and like was
over there looking at something he would
just take the wallet yeah well how long
can that last
I don't know that's like you got a [ __ ]
ton of how many went all over the
[ __ ] place yeah yeah so the other
girls that was in the apartment like
eight blocks in the sorority I was
before every place had a camera in it
well yeah like I said you wouldn't be
able to get away with this just no [ __ ]
nowadays you could maybe get away with
it for a very very very short time you'd
maybe catch you like immediately and
they'd convict easily because your face
would be everywhere and your [ __ ] DNA
and be everywhere holy [ __ ] yeah so yeah
the the other woman that he attacked her
name was Cheryl Thomas and she was also
an FSU student she was a dancer and he
again beat the [ __ ] out of her he's just
like beating in them in the head is
essentially what he's doing
broke her jaw also broke her skull in
five places
she was actually she lived but she was
left permanently deaf and she couldn't
dance anymore because he [ __ ] up her
balance he [ __ ] up her ears and her
skull Jim of the guy just has nothing
but just unbound he's a psycho
he raped her as well with just
unbounding rage and hatred towards women
going back to his mom yeah his mom and
his first girlfriend
early childhood situations it's a bunch
of problems at once is what he's got
yeah one problem alone wouldn't wouldn't
cause her DeStorm one problem one
problem alone wouldn't cause a man to do
this this is several problems all at the
same time that's what I said and like I
said I say this about a lot of serial
killers I don't think I don't think
anyone's completely born bad as they say
cuz I know there's this big nature
versus nurture type of thing like what
makes a psychopath what makes a serial
killer I think it has to be
a perfect storm of ingredients those
things have to be present you have to
have yes you can have a predisposition
for that but if you're born with it and
you grow up in like a normal loving
family you might be alright I'm
convinced that there are a lot of
Psychopaths they're probably all I've
known lots of them but most of them I
think are just high-functioning
Psychopaths yeah never commit any crimes
yeah they're just people that they
actually kind of they get involved in
business and they do certain things and
they rise to a certain level and they
[ __ ] over other people and it doesn't
last long and then they fall back to a
date some of them are a little bit
better and then go up and they can
achieve high things
yeah they [ __ ] over other people and
they become what they would call great
mend you know I mean it's just you know
it's well like I said I think that
several factors have to be present yeah
you have to have a predisposition you
have to have a particular upbringing and
probably you have to have some other
fucked-up [ __ ] happen to you in your
life for you to go to that extreme I
mean I think it's very rare I don't
think psychopathy is that rare but you
know sadly but I do think there has to
be a bunch of other factors going on
before you start because yeah being a
psychopath just war sociopath that's
just one thing that is wrong with them
they got other [ __ ] do like people may
not want to hang out with you yes you
are born like that but yeah you might be
a douche but you might be probably not a
serial killer
so okay so after this [ __ ] horror
show um so then he goes to he steals a
band from FSU and then he goes to
Jacksonville now the first person he a
person is a 14 year old girl named
Leslie Parmenter now he said to her I'm
from the fire department
my name is Richard Burton Richard Burton
yes I was like well she would know and
um so you know you need to come with me
or whatever
now her older brother then showed up it
was like what the [ __ ] and then so then
he took off but then he goes back to
like he turns around he drives like six
miles he goes to Lake City Florida with
her in the car no she got away okay um
but she reported later thought this dude
had come up and then her brother was
like turn off man what are you talking
about little sister for okay so you know
come on you big brother
all right um so then he goes to Lake
City he goes to Lake City junior high
school and he opposed that going that
he's going to junior high schools and
trying to pick up little girls so yeah
it's back to what I was telling you he
did kill all those little girls yeah I
think he did yeah yeah so then he goes
and then there's a twelve-year-old girl
named Kimberly leach now she had gone to
I think she went to PE but then her
teacher was like oh you forgot your
purse in the homeroom so she was going
back to get it and she disappeared at
that you know in between so they didn't
actually so actually so Ted Bundy got
her from 12-year old she was 12 years
old yeah um so they didn't find her
until almost two months later they found
her partially mummified remains in a pig
shed that's why I was telling you your
swanee River State Park yeah 35 miles
away he denied that one but he did that
[ __ ] he did that well I'm like I said
the fact that he had approached another
fourteen-year-old girl like you know
several miles away in the same kind of
way like he didn't want to admit to that
[ __ ] that he like them young yeah all
right so finally finally February 12 um
you know he's been living in this
boarding house but he was running out of
money he couldn't pay his rent um he
started to feel like yeah the police
were on to him so he starts driving you
know trying to get the [ __ ] out of there
she was driving across the Panhandle
then he's actually stopped at the
Alabama brand at the Alabama state line
by the Pensacola police because that
they they saw like they checked his
Volkswagen Beetle that he was driving
and they saw that it was stolen so they
arrested him for auto theft now when
they were arresting him Bundy tried to
escape again by kicking the cops legs
out from under him and then running but
fortunately the cop tackled his ass
and arrested his deep inner [ __ ] face
okay he also like kind of fired a
warning shot or whatever yeah so then so
they search yeah so they search his car
David Lee was the same so they searched
his car they find three different IDs
from three different female FSU students
twenty-one stolen credit cards and a
stolen TV so yeah they also found like
some clothing and sunglasses that that
little girl Leslie Parmenter that she
had said that's what that Richard Burton
Fire Department was wearing those pants
and stuff like that now the interesting
thing was when the cop arrested him he
was only arresting him for like for the
stolen car and for that other [ __ ] he
didn't realize that this is like 10
most-wanted fugitive FBI like big fish
type of thing because he was on the ten
most wanted list at this point he didn't
realize he was just like okay well I
arrested him now very famously when Ted
Bundy got arrested by this for this for
the last time he said quote unquote I
wish you had killed me yeah yeah we wish
you had been killed at birth yeah he was
trying to go down in a blaze of glory
yeah so they put him on trial in Florida
for the chayo mega murders because so
they they kind of had to change the
venue a bunch of times because of you
know obviously everybody knew about the
[ __ ] um and again Ted decided that he
was going to serve as his own like they
assigned him cuz he was poor say assign
him like public defenders he had like
four right four or five of them yeah and
they were firing him and yeah and they
were like giving him advice which I
don't think it would have gotten him off
but they actually were gonna get him a
plea bargain they said hey if you um
it's trying to get him life yeah well if
you confess to these murders we will
just give you a flat 75 years and
that'll be the end of it but he would
not do that like he was like no he fires
all his lawyers he wouldn't listen to
them I'm gonna be my own defense I'm
gonna stand apartment up like [ __ ]
question the witnesses and [ __ ] like
that and if you see and the Ted Bundy
tapes they show like
this was kind of the first trial that
was like nationally televised and if you
watch him talking
he's clearly uh nutcase yeah I remember
it as a kid but didn't understand the
magnitude of it yeah I mean like I was
like yeah yeah okay what's on the other
channel yeah I think I remember this
what I remember mostly later on was his
execution I live in Florida so that was
like a big deal where's all over the TV
barbecues out there look like a damn
football game
yeah they had like big signs like burn
bundi burn yeah I remember that very
vividly I was like I said I'm from
Florida
now the creepiest thing about this is
what he would and they showed part of
this on the Ted Bundy tapes to like what
he would do was when he was questioning
one of the witnesses like one of the
cops or something well can you describe
what exactly the victim looked like like
he was getting them to describe it like
in excruciating detail so he could like
relive it yeah and it was clear that
that's what he was doing
it was super creepy and I don't know why
the judge [ __ ] allowed that because
that was obvious that's what he was
doing
yeah well how was her arm laying how was
this that and the other oh it was so
[ __ ] creepy but yeah so basically
like I said they tried to get him to
take a plea bargain they're like look
just confessed to these murders we'll
give you 75 years and we can all go home
but of course he wouldn't do that so
they were trying to get him to death
penalty and because he was a dumb [ __ ]
that thought he could defend himself he
did end up getting the [ __ ] death
penalty and good riddance
yeah I think I wanted to have the death
Town's yeah I mean the thing about it is
he couldn't live a life what being able
to go out and kill women and people that
knew him said that the reason that he
wouldn't take the plea bargain because
initially he said he would but then he
said no no I'm not gonna do that
um they said the reason that maybe he
didn't do that is because that meant
that he'd have to stand up in front of
everybody and say that he's guilty and
see and say that he and he really did
not want to do that yeah like he still
wanted to maintain the image
of those innocence then he was this good
guy and everything like but it was
obvious it was obvious
yes obvious ed he was guilty and he had
in he had like these had a groupie he
had a group of groupies yeah but one of
them actually married him from well
Carolyn Boone like I said she'd known
him for a really long time like he met
her like a long time many kids with him
dating her a long time
he and nook his semen into her somehow
during a visit well and she had a couple
of his kids evidently just one one but
um yeah that was the whole thing like he
found out that apparently in Florida I
don't know if the law is the same now
but apparently if you make a marriage
declaration like in a courtroom in front
of a judge yeah um
then it's legal yeah so when he was when
Carolyn Boone who was his like his
biggest supporter pretty much he used to
smuggle like money into him in prison
and stuff yeah so when she was on the
stand and he was questioning her at some
point he asked her to marry him and she
said yes so then he said okay well we're
married now and evidently that's legal
now even though at the time he was on
they put him on death row and you
weren't allowed to have conjugal visits
but evidently that [ __ ] still went on
you could probably pay a guard off
that's kind of what they think happened
because they're not entirely sure if
that was really his baby or fighter
style he did a package and he put the
package in he put it in a turkey do you
think that she thought he was innocent
but the thing about it is she supported
him right up till the point where he
finally like after he got the death
penalty after they put him in prison
they you know after he went through all
the [ __ ] and they he knew he wasn't
getting out then he finally came forward
and said yeah I did this that in the
other even though like I said he mostly
said it in the third person long he
couldn't deal with it
now after he kind of came forth and said
yeah I did this and that um then Carolyn
Boone was like alright [ __ ] you man
well she didn't believe it before I
don't believe that see I believe that
she thought it that she thought he did
it yeah I think she did I think she knew
he was guilty but we need best
up to being guilty she couldn't handle
that poverty scrutiny you know what I
mean and yeah because she will like
that's her boy way yeah really yeah I
think I think she had a thing for I
think she had a thing for killers you
know what I feel I feel bad for that kid
though yeah I mean I hope that kid like
went into [ __ ] hiding I think she
knew she was having some kind of fancy
his other girlfriend knew one reported
and depleted wait times man she knew
what was going on yes she knew he was a
[ __ ] weirdo so he had to go through
um so he got convicted of the the chayo
mega murders he was also went to put on
trial in Orlando where we live for the
trial of Kimberly leach the 12 year old
girl that he had taken from the junior
high school and also got another death
penalty for that so yeah like I said at
this point he finally finally comes
forward and goes yeah I did this on the
other now like I said he never he
wouldn't confess to the younger ones
they tried to put together how many
victims it was generally it's at least
30 um usually they give an average of 35
to 36
although Bundy himself has said oh we'll
add another digit to that and you've got
it so a hundred and thirty six I don't
believe it I don't believe it's that
many lying but there's probably a lot
more that they don't know about like I
said I wrote about some in my in my book
that they suspect that might have been
him but he would never our damn it to it
I remember at the time during the time I
was reading the book and I was starting
to consider well how many other ones
could it have been yeah I don't think it
could have been that many more
I just don't yeah because he didn't have
the money and the time you know and
there weren't that many missing people
from what I remember
yeah his area that fit the victimology I
bet you if there were any more of them
it was in the single digits yeah and
like I said if you go to I mean murder
PDA or anything like that's about Ted
Bundy they will give you like a little
rundown of ones that they're pretty sure
we're him because it was very similar MO
and it was yeah you know at the time
when he was known to be in that area or
whatever and it's
not that many more but six seven yeah I
suspect that the total I think it's more
than 36 but it's probably between 40 and
50 I'm gonna say but that's a very rough
estimate right it could very well be
more than that I'm not really sure
because if there were more of them that
he could have proved cuz he actually did
it yeah you would think he would have
gone on a confession spree kind of like
oh what's his name
yeah and then bought himself more time
on death row he tried to do that um
there when he was going through all the
appeals cuz like I said in Florida and
probably in other states that saw the
death penalty like I said back then it
was still the electric chair he was
trying to he got several stays of
execution because you get a certain
amount of Appeals because the death
penalty they can't reduce they can't
undo that [ __ ] so he what he would do
was he would like tease that he had more
victim or he would tell you where the
bodies were you know if he he would get
more time but the judge you know various
judges were like not we know what you're
doing just knock it off and the families
of the victims whose bodies had never
been found they said the same thing
there so don't let him do that right
just [ __ ] kill is that because Henry
Lee we know that are you know we know
that our family members dead we know
that he did it um you know please just
kill him cuz Henry Lucas made a whole
[ __ ] career of confessing to [ __ ] and
he didn't do yeah and I would so he
could go on little trips yeah and I
would think that Bundy would have done
the same thing if it were possible yeah
and there were any other ones that they
didn't know about it's in the single
digits I don't think he was that
prodigious I don't think he had the
physical I don't think he had the the
financial prowess you know I mean yeah
to pay for these hunting trips did do
this yeah like I said say something that
was kind of um I'm not even sure if he
if he like meant to say it this is
bluntly but he did say something later
on to one of his biographers that if
they were too young or too close to home
like he didn't want to talk about them
so there might have been more like I
said they think that he killed some that
were maybe some Braille under-16 or
people that lived around him or lived in
his neighborhood or something like that
they think not just close in like family
but close in like proximity you know
what I mean because he did say something
like that like that was once he wouldn't
like it [ __ ] he says like I said
there's no way of knowing there's no way
man he talked and there certainly are
like some cases that they think were
probably him but they couldn't prove it
so they did actually fries ass in old
Sparky the electric chair On January
24th 1989 he was 42 years old and as I
said I remember very very vividly I was
17 at the time yeah I was a junior in
high school in 1989 and I remember this
being on the news there was huge huge
parties it was like it was like a
[ __ ] block party outside of the
[ __ ] prison on the day that he was
exiting in the morning he was executed
there was just people they were having
[ __ ] cookouts that was like [ __ ]
everybody had [ __ ] signs like they
were so happy they were selling like
little gold tie pins of electric chairs
and [ __ ] like that before I was kind of
[ __ ] up but you know I went into the
Army what year was it what month was it
89 January it is January 9 yeah okay
yeah I remember it and then not long
after that the first Gulf War started
starting to brew that might have been
ten months later something like that and
that's when I joined the army yeah but I
remember seeing it on the news on CNN
yeah watching those parties outside
that's back when CNN would repeat itself
well yeah yeah yeah well cause like I
said we didn't I mean until the 80s we
didn't have like 24-hour news channels
no you needed like content for all this
yeah some stories would disappear in
Newport News stories would appear and
one of them was just what was going on
over there during the execution of yeah
it was a trip now interestingly and this
is another part of the [ __ ] of Ted
Bundy is that shortly before his
execution he had a meeting with James
Dobson and if you don't remember who he
is he was that evangelist sort of like
Focus on the Family that [ __ ] crazy
is
James Dobson you don't remember that guy
no
focus on the family you know in that
show no oh man okay I tried to ignore
that kind of [ __ ] back in me Tama so he
he talks to this guy and I think he's
just saying what this dude wants to hear
because this dude was like a big
anti-porn you know Crusader and all that
other kind of [ __ ] oh that was super
mine to kill people yeah Mundy was
trying to blame all of it porn on porn
in an indirect way man that [ __ ] didn't
have any porn in his car he lived out of
his car and he's like basically he was
saying [ __ ] like oh well all this like
super violent porn it's like leading
other boys to be like Ted Bundy's and
maybe you should knock that off yeah
yeah so that was some [ __ ] and like I
said he also told some biographers he
was into those like like you said those
true-crime kind of magazines but then he
told other ones I don't know so yeah he
was he was one of those guys that always
seemed like he wanted to like blame
someone else one of the most horrible
things he said and this is a [ __ ]
quote directly from him where he was
taught and he said this to his
girlfriend he said he was talking about
victims or like some people that were
like born to be victims kind of he says
their facial expressions say I'm afraid
of you like he says I've known people
who radiate vulnerability their facial
expressions say I'm afraid of you these
people invite abuse by expecting to be
hurt do they subtly encourage it wait
I'm like are you subtly inviting me to
kick you in the tank because I'm gonna
do that detecting I think yeah that's
what I mean so he always seemed like he
was one of those dudes it was always
like someone else's well it's their
fault it's always somebody else's you
know
[ __ ] don't like me they're scared of
me so I killed her so I killed her blah
blah that's so yeah so for a second like
like I said there were some there was a
handful of other cases that they think
might have been him you know we'll just
kind of go through those real quick like
I said anne-marie burn with the
eight-year-old that they think that
might have been kidnapped and murdered
by him when he was 14 years old there
were also these two flight attendants
Lisa wick and Lonnie Jerome
they were both bludgeoned with a piece
of lumber as they slept in their
apartment that was in Seattle I was like
in 1966 he was in that area um yeah and
he lived there at the time and he
actually worked at a grocery store like
very near where that apartment was now
one of them died the other one survived
but she didn't
she couldn't like remember what the guy
looked like there were also two other
ones Susan Davis and Elizabeth Perry
these were both 19 year olds they were
stabbed to death in 1969 so he was
taught high school dear ones yeah that
was in New Jersey that's high school
that's high school years 1569 yeah or
yeah high school and right around the
time he was starting college yeah um
yeah cuz yeah yeah yeah cuz he was in
Temple University so he was in college
in 1969
that's him so that wasn't that far away
that's him uh Rita Curran uh I read
about her in my book she was 24 years
old she was an elementary school teacher
and a part-time hotel maid she was also
murdered again basement apartment 1971
Burlington Vermont and that was Ted
Bundy's hometown strangled bludgeoned
and raped the same MO and the the motel
where she worked at was very near the
unwed mothers place where Ted Bundy had
been born so he saw yeah well he was
born there so he wasn't there when she
was working at the place but well yeah
but he went back there to visit yes so
they think that he was in the area at
the time there was another girl named
Joyce LePage who was 21 she vanished in
July of 1971 from the campus of
Washington State University and then her
skeleton was found nine months later in
another part of Washington there was
another girl named Rita jolly seventeen
disappeared from Westland Oregon in June
of 1973 Vicki Lynne Haller 24
disappeared from Eugene Oregon August
20th 1973 now Ted Bundy actually
confessed to two murders in Oregon but
didn't say what their names were so they
think that these two are maybe the ones
he was talking about here's another 14
year old girl Katherine
devine abducted November 25th 1973 body
found in the Capitol State Forest near
Olympia Washington also brenda joy Baker
who was 14 disappeared in a city in
Washington in May 1974 body found a
month later he said that he wouldn't
confess to these two but they're
suspecting that maybe maybe maybe
they're although there was DNA in one of
the cases that pointed to maybe point it
to someone else there was another woman
named Sandra Jean Weaver 19 she was last
seen in Salt Lake City July 1st 1974 and
discovered the next day dead in Grand
Junction Colorado Carol Valenzuela who
was 20 years old last seen hitchhiking
near Vancouver Washington August 2nd
1974 her remains discovered two months
later in a shallow grave south of
Olympia shallow grave yeah remember
Bundy everbearing anybody he would kind
of like put them out in the woods or
maybe put some dirt over like it just he
wanted to come back to them so yeah you
know okay so um there was another woman
found with this uh with this victim
whose name was Martha Morrison she was
also 17 and she had been taken from
Eugene Oregon in September of 1974 so
they think that Bundy had passed through
there around that time so this is also
possible
Melanie Cooley 18 disappeared April 15
1975 after leaving her high school in
Nederland Colorado found bludgeoned and
strangled by road maintenance workers
two weeks later in Coal Creek Canyon
which was 20 miles away they actually
found gas station receipts that put
Bundy in that area on that day so
they're kind of thinking maybe that was
him also
Shelley Robertson who was 24 this
happened Golden Colorado July 1975 her
new decomposed body was found in August
inside a mineshaft
it could also gas receipts placed Bundy
in this area at the time of the
disappearance as well it could be the
Bundy killed women or forgot about it
well like I said there comes a point
where if he really did kill all these
women I mean that's a lot of women
yeah you might remember all of them I
would think that's a spooky thought when
you think about it yes I mean I can't
remember long yeah it's like I think I
don't know well I mean I know I guess
they kind of get used to it yeah well I
know it's [ __ ] up but like you know I
don't remember a lot of stuff like from
day to day later years later you don't
remember that [ __ ] so even if you're
killing people if you do it enough times
get used to it you might get along all
the victims will just run together
[ __ ] up that's why yeah
yeah so there was that one Nancy Barrett
who was 23 disappeared from a gas
station where she was employed in Utah
she is they actually never found her so
she's still a missing person
there was a girl named Debbie Smith who
was 17 last seen in Salt Lake City in
February 1976 body found near Salt Lake
City International Airport in April of
1970 City killed a hundred more but
chances are based on the victimology the
locations and the ones that the
professionals are offering to us the
ones that you're reading right now these
are probably the other ones he's talking
about that's what I'm saying yeah I
think it's probably more like 50 ish
yeah like around 50 oh yeah
um like I think he killed more people
than they think yeah but I don't think
it was like a hunter and I guarantee I
don't think I guarantee he forgot a lot
of them he probably did and it's not
really quite sure himself
cuz like he was just like [ __ ] around
like hey I'm going to Utah him go to
Washington and Vermont and it's like
while he was I mean while he was driving
from place to place he might have
pitched picked up hitchhikers raped him
threw him out in the [ __ ] river
somewhere and forgot about it right
because like some of the confessions he
made I was like yeah I think I picked up
two hitchhikers and killed him in
[ __ ] Colorado and he didn't remember
eat another names or anything if you did
it once or twice or three times or four
times you'd never forget about it but if
you did it 50 times some of them you'd
forget about that's what I mean you
wouldn't remember and especially like I
said he used to like driving around
doing that [ __ ] all the time
yeah that is messed up all right yeah I
can't he's all weasel he's been done
a long time but yeah so we've gone on
and on like we usually do but wrap it up
rapidly hopefully you guys found this
entertaining this was actually a really
interesting show
for me to do it's you know even though a
lot of people Ted Bundy's very famous
and like I said the Netflix series
everything like that but I kind of
wanted to you know do our take on it our
take on we like to do that kind of stuff
so hopefully you guys found it
interesting and enlightening and
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe on all your social media if
you'd like to financially support the
show would be much appreciated you can
go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin the clock podcast
stop for a press calm and there's a
button in the sidebar that says donate
via PayPal so you can give a one-time
donation you get a monthly donation you
do it ever the hell you want to do buy
books you can borrow so I've got all
kind of books all kind of games all kind
of [ __ ] you can buy we got t-shirts on
Zazzle we got all that [ __ ] going on you
guys know also check out our last movie
review which was the Clint Eastwood
supernatural Western High Plains Drifter
ride the cool ass movie let's go check
that out if you haven't already yeah and
until next time we will see you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]